hey I'm maybe from deep lizard and in
this course we're going to learn how to
use Karis a neural network API written
in Python and integrated with tensor
flow throughout the course each lesson
will focus on a specific deep learning
concept and show the full implementation
in code using the Charis api we'll be
starting with the absolute basics of
learning how to organize and pre process
data and then we'll move on to building
and training our own artificial neural
networks and some of these networks will
be built from scratch and others will be
pre trained state-of-the-art models for
which will fine tune to use on our own
custom data sets now let's discuss the
prerequisites needed to follow along
with this course from a knowledge
standpoint we'll give brief
introductions of each deep learning
concept that we are going to work with
before we go through the code
implementation but if you're an absolute
beginner to deep learning then we first
recommend you go through the deep
learning fundamental scores on deep
lasercom or if you're super eager to
jump into the code then you can
simultaneously take this course and the
deep learning fundamentals course the
deep learning fundamentals course will
give you all the knowledge you need to
know to get acquainted with major deep
learning concepts for which then you can
come back and implement and code using
the Charis api in this course in regards
to coding prerequisites just some basic
programming skills and some Python
experience are all that's needed on
people sure comm you can also find the
deep learning learning path so you can
see where this Kerris course falls
amidst all the deep lizard deep learning
content now let's discuss the course
resources so aside from the videos here
on YouTube you will also have video and
text resources available on deep lizard
calm and actually each episode has its
own corresponding blog and quiz
available for you to take and test your
own knowledge and you can actually
contribute your own quiz questions as
well
you can see how to do that on the
corresponding blog for each episode
additionally all of the code resources
used in this course are regularly tested
and maintained including updates and bug
fixes when the
download access to code files used in
this course are available to members of
the peoples or hivemind so you can check
out more about that on be Blizzard comm
as well alright so now that we know what
this course is about and what resources
we have available along with the
prerequisites needed to get started
let's now talk a little bit more about
Kerris itself
caris was developed with a focus on
enabling fast user experimentation so
this allows us to go from idea to
implementation and very few steps aside
from this benefit users often wonder why
choose caris as the neural network API
to learn or in general which neural
network API should they learn our
general advice is to not commit yourself
just to only learning one and sticking
with that one
forever we recommend to learn multiple
neural network KPIs and the idea is that
once you have a fundamental
understanding of the underlying concepts
then the miners syntactical and
implementation differences between the
neural network api's shouldn't really be
that hard to catch on to once you have
at least one under your belt already
especially for job prospects knowing
more than one neural network API will
show your experience and allow you to
compare and contrast the differences
between api's and share your opinions
for why you think that certain api's may
be better for certain problems and
others for other problems being able to
demonstrate this will make you a much
more valuable candidate now we
previously touched on the fact that
Kerris is integrated with tensorflow
so let's discuss that more now
historically Kerris was a high-level
neural network API that you could
configure to run against one of three
separate lower-level api's and those
little rollable api's were tensorflow
Theano
and c NT k later though caris became
fully integrated with the tensorflow api
and is no longer a separate library that
you can choose to run against one of the
three back-end engines that we discussed
previously so it's important to
understand that Kerris is now completely
integrated with the tensorflow api but
in this course we are going to be
focusing on making use solely of that
high-level Kerris API without necessary
making much use of the lower-level
tensorflow api now before we can start
working with Karis then we first have to
obviously get it downloaded and
installed on to our machines and the
cost carriers is fully integrated with
tensorflow
we can do that by just installing Kinser
flow cares will come completely packaged
with the tensorflow installation so the
installation procedure is as simple as
running pip install tensorflow
from your command line you might just
want to check out the system
requirements on Kinser flows website to
make sure that your specific system
meets the requirements needed for
tensorflow to install alright so we have
one last talking point before we can get
into the actual meet of the coding and
that is about GPU support so the first
important thing to note is that a GPU is
not required to follow this course if
you're running your machine only on a
CPU then that is totally fine for what
we'll be doing in the course if however
you do want to run your code on a GPU
then you can do so pretty easily after
you get through the setup process for
setting up your GPU to work with
tensorflow
we have a full guide on how to get the
GPU set up to work with tensorflow on
deep laser comm so if you are interested
in doing that then head over there to go
through those steps but actually I
recommend just going through the course
with a CPU if you're not already set up
with a GPU and like I said the all the
code will work completely fine run
totally fine using only a CPU but then
after the fact after you go through the
course successfully
then get the steps in order to work with
the GPU if you have one and then run all
the code that you have in place from
earlier run it on the GPU the second
go-round and just kind of look and see
the kind of efficiency and speed ups
that you'll see in the code alright so
that's it for the Charis introduction
now we're finally ready to jump in to
the code be sure to check out the blog
and other resources available for this
episode on beep laser comm as well as
the depot's archive mind where you can
gain access to exclusive perks and
rewards thanks for contributing to
collective intelligence now let's move
on to the next episode
hey I may be from deep lizard in this
episode we'll learn how to prepare and
process numerical data that will later
use to train our very first artificial
neural network to train any neural
network in a supervised learning task we
first need a data set of samples along
with the corresponding labels for those
samples when referring to the word
samples were simply just talking about
the underlying data set where each data
point in the set is referred to as a
sample if we were to train a model to do
sentiment analysis on headlines from a
media source for example then the labels
that correspond to each headline sample
would be positive or negative or say
that we were training an artificial
neural network to identify images as
cats or dogs well then that would mean
that each image would have a
corresponding label of cat or dog
note that in deep learning you may also
hear samples referred to as inputs or
input data and you may hear a labels
referred to as targets or target data
when preparing a data set we first need
to understand the task for which the
data will be used and our example will
be using our data set to train an
artificial neural network so once we
understand this then we can understand
which format the data needs to be in in
order for us to be able to pass the data
to the network the first type of neural
network that we'll be working with is
called a sequential model from the
Charis API and we'll discuss more
details about the sequential model in a
future episode but for now we just need
to understand what type of data format
the sequential model expects so that we
can prepare our data set accordingly the
sequential model receives data during
training whenever we call the fit
function on it and again we're going to
go into more details about this function
in the future but for now let's check
out what type of data format the fit
function expects so if we look at the
fit documentation here on concern
website we can see the first two
parameters that the fit function expects
are x and y so x is our input data our
samples in other words so this function
expects X our input data to be in a
numpy array at pincer flow tensor
addicting at EF data data set or a
Karass generator so if you're not
familiar with all of these data types
that's okay because for our first
example we are going to organize our
data to be in a numpy array so the first
option here in the documentation so this
is for our input samples but also the Y
parameter that is expected by the fit
function is our data set that contains
the corresponding labels for our samples
so the target data now the requirement
for Y is that it is formatted as one of
the above formats that we just discussed
for X but Y needs to be in the same
format as X so we can't have our samples
contained in a numpy array for example
and then have Y our target data or our
labels for those samples and a
tensorflow tensor so the format of x and
y both need to match and we're going to
be putting both of those into numpy
arrays alright so now we know the data
format that the model expects but
there's another reason that we may want
to transform or process our data and
that is to put it in a format that will
make it easier or more efficient for the
model to learn from and we can do that
with data normalization or
standardization techniques data
processing and deep learning will vary
greatly depending on the type of data
that we're working with so to start out
we are going to work with a very simple
numerical data set to train our model
and later we'll get exposure to working
with different types of data as well
alright so now we're ready to prepare
and process our first data set so we are
in our jupiter notebook in the first
step is to import all the packages that
we'll be making use of including numpy
random and some modules from
scikit-learn next we will create two
lists one call
train samples one called train labels
and these lists will hold the
corresponding samples and labels for our
data set now about this data set we are
going to be working with a very simple
numerical data set and so for this task
we're actually going to create the data
ourselves later we'll work with more
practical examples and realistic ones
where where we won't be creating the
data but instead downloading it from
some external source but for now we're
going to create this data ourselves for
which we'll train our first artificial
neural network so as a motivation for
this kind of dummy data we have this
background story to give us an idea of
what this data is all about so let's
suppose that an experimental drug was
tested on individuals ranging from age
13 to 100 in a clinical trial this trial
had 20 100 participants total half of
these participants were under the age of
65 and half were 65 years or older and
the conclusions from this trial was that
around 95 percent of the patients who
were in the older populations as 65 or
older the 95 percent of those patients
experienced side effects and around 95
percent of patients who were under 65
years old experienced no side effects
okay so this is a very simplistic data
set and so that is the background story
now and this cell here we're going to go
through the process of actually creating
that data set so what this is is this
first for loop is going to generate both
the approximately 5% of younger
individuals who did experience side
effects and the 5% of older individuals
who did not experience side effects so
within this first four loop we are first
generating a random number or a random
integer rather between 13 and 64 and
that is constituting as a younger
individual who is under 65 years of age
or yeah who's under 65 years of age and
we are going to then append this number
to the trained samples list and then we
append a one to the train
Abel's list now a1 is representing the
fact that a patient did experience side
effects and a0 would represent a patient
who did not experience side effects so
then similarly we jump down to the next
line and we are generating a random
integer between 65 and 100 to represent
the older population and we are doing
that remember this is in our first for
loop so it's only running 50 times so
this is kind of the outlier group these
5% of older individuals who did not
experience side effects so we then it
take that sample append it to the
trained samples list and append a zero
to the corresponding train labels list
since these patients were the older
patients who did not experience side
effects so then if we jump down to the
next for loop very similarly we have
pretty much the same code here except
for this is the the bulk of the group in
this for loop we are running this for
the 95 percent of younger individuals
who did not experience side effects as
well as the 95 percent of older
individuals who did experience side
effects so generating a random number
between 13 and 64 and then appending
that number representing the age of the
younger population to the train samples
list and appending the label of a zero
since these individuals did not
experience side effects were pending a
zero to the train labels list similarly
we do the same thing for the older
individuals from 65 to 100 except for
since the majority of these guys did
experience side effects we are appending
a 1 to the train labels list so just to
summarize we have the samples list that
contains a bunch of integers ranging
from 13 to 100 and then we have the
Train labels list that has the labels
that correspond to each of these
individuals with the ages 13 to 100 the
labels correspond to whether or not
these individuals experience side
effects so a samples list containing
ages labels list containing zeros and
ones representing side effects or no
side effects and just to get a
visualization of the same
here we are printing out all of the
samples in our list and we see that
these are just all integers like we'd
expect ranging from 13 to 100 and then
correspondingly if we run our train
labels list and print out all of the
data there then we can see this list
contains a bunch of zeros and ones all
right so now the next step is to take
these lists and then start processing
them so we have our data generated and
now we need to process it to be in the
format for which we saw the fit function
expects and we discussed the fact that
we are going to be passing this data as
numpy arrays to the fit function so our
next step is to go ahead and do that
transformation here where we are taking
the train labels list and making that
now a numpy array
similarly doing the same thing with the
training samples list and then we use
the shuffle function to shuffle both our
train labels and a train samples
respective to each other so that we can
get rid of any imposed order from the
data generation process okay so now the
data is in the numpy array format that
is expected by the fit function but as
mentioned earlier there's another reason
that we might want to do further
processing on the data and that is to
either normalize or standardize it so
that we can get it in such a way that
the training of the neural network might
become quicker or more efficient and so
that's what we're doing in this cell now
we are using this min max scalar object
to create a feature range ranging from 0
to 1 which will then use in this next
line to rescale our data from the
current scale of 13 to 100 down to a
scale of 0 to 1 and then this reshaping
that we're doing here is just a
formality because the fit transform
function doesn't accept 1d data by
default since our data is
one-dimensional we have to reshape it in
this way to be able to pass it to the
fit transform function so now if we
print out the elements in our new scaled
train at samples variable which that's
what we're calling our news
scaled samples then we can print them
out and see that now the individual
elements are no longer integers ranging
from 13 to 100 but instead we have these
values ranging anywhere between zero and
one so at this point we have generated
some raw data and then processed it to
be in a numpy array format that our
model will expect and then rescale the
data to be on a scale between zero and
one in an upcoming episode we'll use
this data to train our first artificial
neural network be sure to check out the
blog and other resources available for
this episode on the Blizzard calm as
well as the depot's archive mind where
you can gain access to exclusive perks
and rewards thanks for contributing to
collective intelligence now let's move
on to the next episode
hey I'm Mandy from deep lizard in this
episode we'll demonstrate how to create
an artificial neural network using a
sequential model from the Charis api
integrated within tensorflow in the last
episode we generated data from an
imagined clinical trial and now we'll
create an artificial neural network for
which we can train on this data alright
so first things first we need to import
all of the tensorflow modules that we'll
be making use of to build our first
model and that includes everything that
you see here except for actually the
last two of atom and categorical cross
inventory categorical cross entropy
rather those two are going to be used
when we train the model not when we
build it but we're going ahead and
bringing all the imports in and now and
then next if you are running this code
on a GPU then you can run this cell
which will allow you to make sure that
tensorflow
is correctly identifying your GPU as
well as enable memory growth and there's
a few lines on the blog where you can
check out what exactly that means and
why you might want to do this but if you
are running a GPU then go ahead and
this cell so next this is the actual
model that we are building this is a
sequential model and that is kind of the
most simplest type of model that you can
build using Kerris or tensorflow and a
sequential model can be described as a
linear stack of layers so if you look at
how we're creating the model here that's
exactly what it looks like so we are
initializing the model as an instance of
the sequential class and we are passing
in a list of layers here now it's
important to note that this first dense
layer that we're looking at that is
actually the second layer overall so
this is the first hidden layer and
that's because the input layer were not
explicitly defining using cares the
input data is what creates the input
layer itself so the way that the model
knows what type of input data to expect
or the shape of the input data rather is
through this input shape parameter that
we pass to our first dense layer so
through this the model understands the
shape of the input data that it should
expect and then therefore it accepts
that shape of input data and then passes
that data to the first hidden layer
which is this dense layer here in our
case now we are telling this dense layer
that we want it to have 16 units these
units are also otherwise known as nodes
or neurons and the choice of 16 here is
actually pretty arbitrary this model
overall is very simple and with the
arbitrary choice of nodes here it's
actually going to be pretty hard to
create a simple model at least that
won't do a good job at classifying this
data just given the simplicity of the
data itself so we understand that we're
passing in or that we're specifying 16
units for this first hidden layer we are
specifying the input shape so that the
model knows the shape of the input data
to expect and then we are stating that
we want the value activation function to
follow this dense layer
now this input shape parameter is only
specified for our first hidden layer so
after that we have one more hidden dense
layer this time we are arbitrarily
setting the number of units for this
dense layer to be 32 and again we're
following the layer by the activation
function value and then lastly we
specify our last output layer or our
last layer which is our output layer
this is another dense layer this time
with only two units and that is
corresponding to the two possible output
classes either a patient did experience
side effects or the patient did not
experience side effects and we're
following this output layer with the
softmax function which is just going to
give us probabilities for each output
class so between whether or not a
patient experience side effects or not
we will have an output probability for
each class letting us know which class
is more probable for any given patient
and just in case it's not clear this
dense layer here is what we call a
densely connected layer or a fully
connected layer probably the most
well-known type of layer and in
artificial neural networks now in case
you need any refresher on fully
connected layers or activation functions
or anything else that we've discussed up
to this point then just know that all
that is covered in the deep learning
fundamentals course if you need to go
there and refresh your memory on any of
these topics here
alright so now we'll run this cell to
create our model and now we can use
model dot summary to print out a visual
summary of the architecture of the model
we just created so looking here we can
just see the visual representation of
the architecture that we just created in
the cell above alright so now we have
just finished creating our very first
neural network using this simple and
intuitive sequential model type in the
next episode we will see how we can use
the data that we created last time to
train this network be sure to check out
the blog and other resources available
for this episode on beep laser comm as
well as the
people's our hive mind where you can
gain access to exclusive perks and
rewards thanks for contributing to
collective intelligence now let's move
on to the next episode
hey I'm Mandy from deep lizard in this
episode we'll see how to train an
artificial neural network using the
Charis api integrated with tensorflow
[Music]
in previous episodes we went through
steps to generate data and also build an
artificial neural network so now we'll
bring these two together to actually
train the network on the data that we
created and processed all right so
picking up where we were last time in
our jupiter notebook make sure that you
still have all of your imports included
and already ran so that we can continue
where we were before so first we have
after building our model we are going to
call this model dot compiled function
and this just prepares the model for
training so it gets everything in order
that's needed before we can actually
train the model so first we are
specifying to the compile function what
optimizer that we want to use and we are
choosing to use the very common
optimizer atom with a learning rate of
0.0001 and next we specify the type of
loss that we need to use which is in our
case we're going to use sparse
categorical cross n but we're going to
use sparse categorical cross entropy and
then lastly we specify what metrics we
want to see so this is just for the
model performance what we want to be
able to judge our model by and we are
specifying this list which just includes
accuracy which is a very common way to
be able to evaluate model performance so
if we run this cell alright so the model
has been compiled and is ready for
training and training occurs whenever we
call this fit function now recall
earlier in the course we actually looked
at the documentation for the spit
function so that we knew how to process
our input data so to fit the first
parameter that we're specifying is X
here which is
input data which is currently stored in
this scale to Train samples variable
then Y which is our target data or our
labels our labels are currently stored
in the Train
labels variable so we are specifying
that here next we specify our batch size
that we want to use for training so this
is how many samples are included in one
batch to be passed in processed by the
network at one time so we're setting
this to ten and the number of epochs
that we want to run we're setting this
to 30 so that means that the model is
going to process or train on all of the
data in the data set 30 times before
completing the total training process
next we're specifying this shuffle
shuffle parameter which we are setting
to true now by default this is already
set to true but I was just bringing it
to your attention to show to make you
aware of the fact that the data is being
shuffled by default when we pass it to
the network which is a good thing
because we want any order that is inside
of the data set to be kind of erased
before we pass the data to the model so
that the model is not necessarily
learning anything about the order of the
data set so this is true by default so
we don't necessarily have to specify
that I was just letting you know and
actually we'll see something about that
in the next episode about why this is
important regarding validation data but
we'll see that coming up the last
parameter that we specify here is
verbose which is just an option to allow
us to see output from whenever we run
this fit function so we can either set
it to 0 1 or 2 2 is the most verbose
level in terms of output messages so we
are setting that here so that we can get
the highest level of output so now let's
run the cell so that training can begin
alright so training has just stopped and
we have run for 30 epochs and if we look
at the progress of the model so we're
starting out on our first epoch our lost
value is currently 0.68 and our accuracy
is 50% so no better than chance but
pretty quickly looking at
accuracy we can tell that it is steadily
increasing all the way until we get to
our last epoch which we are yielding 94%
accuracy and our losses also steadily
decrease from the 0.65 range to now
being at point two seven so as you can
see the this model trained very quickly
with each epoch taking only under one
second to run and within 30 Hawks we are
already at a 94% accuracy rate now
although this is a very simple model and
we were training it on very simple data
we can see that without much effort at
all we were able to yield pretty great
results in a relatively quick manner of
time as well in subsequent episodes
we'll demonstrate how to work with more
complex models as well as more complex
data but for now hopefully this example
serve the purpose of encouraging you on
how easy it is to get started with Karis
be sure to check out the blog and other
resources available for this episode on
beep laser comm as well as the depot's
archive mind where you can gain access
to exclusive perks and rewards thanks
for contributing to collective
intelligence now let's move on to the
next episode hey I may be from beef
lizard in this episode we'll demonstrate
how we can use tensorflow scaris API to
create a validation set on the fly
during training
[Music]
before we demonstrate how to build a
validation set using Kharis let's first
talk about what exactly a validation set
is so whenever we train a model our hope
is that when we train it that we see
good results from the training output
that we have low loss and high accuracy
but we don't ever train a model just for
the sake of training it we want to take
that model and hopefully be able to use
it in some way on data that it wasn't
necessarily exposed to during the
training process and although this new
data is data that the models never seen
before the hope is that the model will
be good enough to be able to generalize
well on this new data and give accurate
predictions for it we can actually get
an understanding of how well our model
is generalizing by introducing a
validation set during the training
process to create a validation set
before training begins we can choose to
take a subset of the training set and
then separate it into a separate set
labeled as validation data and then
during the training process the model
will only train on the training data and
then we'll validate on the separated
validation data so what do we mean by
validating well essentially if we have
the addition of a validation set
then during training the model will be
learning the features of the training
set just as we've already seen but in
addition in each epoch after the model
has gone through the actual training
process it'll take what it's learned
from the training data and then validate
by predicting on the data in the
validation set using only what it's
learned from the training data though so
then during the training process when we
look at the output of the accuracy and
loss not only will we be seeing that
accuracy and loss computed for the
training set we'll also see that
computed on the validation set it's
important to understand though that the
model is only learning on or training on
the training data it's not taking the
validation set into account during
training the validation set is just for
us to be able to see how well the model
is able to predict on data
it was not exposed to during the
training process in other words it
allows us to see how general our model
is how well it's able to generalize on
data that is not included in the
training data so knowing this
information will allow us to see if our
model is running into the famous
overfitting problem so overfitting
occurs when the model has learned the
specific features of the training set
really well but it's unable to
generalize on data it hasn't seen before
so if while training we see that the
model is giving really good results for
the training set but less than good
results for the validation set then we
can conclude that we have an overfitting
problem and then take the steps
necessary to combat that specific issue
if you'd like to see the overfitting
problem covered in more detail then
there is an episode for that in the deep
learning fundamentals course all right
so now let's discuss how we can create
and use a validation set with a Karass
sequential model there's actually two
ways that we can create and work with
validation sets with a sequential model
and the first way is to have a
completely separate validation set from
the training set and then to pass that
validation set to the model in the fit
function there is a validation data
parameter and so we can just set that
equal to the structure that is holding
our validation data and there's a
write-up in the corresponding blog for
this episode that contains more details
about the format that that data needs to
be in but we're going to actually only
focus on the second way of creating and
using a validation set this step
actually saves us a step because we
don't have to explicitly go through the
creation process of the validation set
instead we can get carest to create it
for us all right so we're back in our
jupiter notebook right where we left off
last time and we're here on the model
dot fit function and recall this is what
we use last time to train our model now
i've already edited this cell to include
this new parameter which is validation
split and what validation split does is
it does what it sounds like it splits
out a portion of the training set into a
validation set
so we just set this to a number between
zero and one so just a fractional number
to tell Karis how much of the training
set we need to split out into the
validation set so here I'm splitting out
10% of the training set so it's
important to note that whenever we do
this the validation set is completely
held out of the training set so the
training samples that we remove from the
training set into validation set are no
longer contained within the training
data any longer so using this approach
the validation set will be created on
the fly whenever we call the fit
function now there's one other thing
worth mentioning here and remember last
time I discussed this shuffle equals
true parameter and I said that by
default the training set is shuffled
whenever we call fit so this shuffle
equals true is already set by default
but I was just bringing it up to let you
know that that the training set is being
shuffled so that is a good thing we want
the training set to be shuffled but
whenever we call validation split in
this way this split occurs before the
training set is shuffled meaning that if
we created our training set and say we
put all of the sick patients first and
then the non sick patients second and
then we say that we want to split off
the last 10% of the training data to be
our validation data it's going to take
the last 10% of the training data and
therefore it could just take all of the
the second group that we put in the
training set and not get any of the
first group so I wanted to mention that
because although the training data is
being shuffled with the fit function if
you haven't already shuffled your
training data before you pass it to fit
then you also use the validation split
parameter it's important to know that
your validation set is going to be the
last X percent of your training set and
therefore may not be shuffled and may
yield some strange results because you
think that everything has been shuffled
when really it's only the training set
has been shuffled after the validations
has been taken out so just keep that in
mind the way that we created our
training set before this episode we
actually shuffled the training data
before it's ever passed to the fit
function so in the future whenever
you're working with data it's a good
idea to make sure that your data is also
shuffled beforehand especially if you're
going to be making use of the validation
split parameter to create a validation
set all right so now we'll run this so
one more time calling the fit function
but this time not only will we see loss
and accuracy metrics for the training
set we'll also see these metrics for the
validation set all right so the model
has just finished running it's 30 epochs
and now we see both the loss and
accuracy on the left hand side as well
as the validation loss and validation
accuracy on the right hand side so we
can see let's just look at the accuracy
between the two they're both starting at
around the same 50 percent mark and
going up gradually around the same rate
so if we just scroll all the way to our
last epoch we can see that the accuracy
and validation accuracy are pretty
similar with only one percent difference
between the two and yeah the loss values
are similar as well so we can see in
this example that our model is not
overfitting it is actually performing
pretty well or just as well rather on
the validation set as it is on the
training set so our model is
generalizing well if however we saw that
the opposite case was true and our
validation accuracy was seriously
lagging behind our training accuracy
then we know that we have a overfitting
problem and we would need to take steps
to address that issue all right so we've
now seen how to train the model how to
validate the model and how to make use
of both training and validation sets in
the next episode we're going to see how
to make use of a third data set the test
data set to use the model for inference
be sure to check out the blog and other
resources available for this episode on
beep laser comm as well as the depot's
archive mind where you can gain access
to exclusive
perks and rewards thanks for
contributing to collective intelligence
now let's move on to the next episode
hey I'm Mandy from bee blizzard in this
episode we'll see how we can use a
neural network for inference to predict
on data from a test set using tensor
flows Karis API as we touched on
previously whenever we train a model the
hope is that we can then take that model
and use it on new data that it has not
seen before during training and
hopefully the model is able to
generalize well and give us good results
on this new data so as a simple example
suppose that we trained a network to be
able to identify images of cats or dogs
and so during the training process of
course we had a training set that say we
downloaded from a website with thousands
of images of cats and dogs so the hope
is later that if we wanted to we could
maybe build a web app for example and we
could have people from all over the
world submit their dog and cat photos
and have our model tell them with high
accuracy whether or not their animal is
a cat or a dog so I don't know why
anyone would actually make that web app
but you get the point the hope is that
even though the images that are being
sent in from people around the world of
their own cats and dogs even though
those weren't included in the training
set that the model was originally
trained on hopefully the model is able
to generalize well enough to understand
from what it's learned about dog and cat
features that it can predict that
Mandy's dog is actually a dog and not a
cat for example we call this process
inference so the model takes what it
learned during training and then uses
that knowledge to infer things about
data that it hasn't seen before in
practice we might hold out a subset of
our training data to put in a set called
the test set typically after the model
has been trained and validated we take
the model and use it for inference
purposes against the test set just as
one additional step to the validation to
make sure that the model is
generalizing well before we deploy our
model to production so at this point the
model that we've been working with over
the last few episodes has been trained
and validated and given the metrics that
we saw during the validation process we
have a good idea that the model is
probably going to do a pretty good job
at inference on the test set as well in
order to conclude that though we first
would need to create a test set so we're
going to do that now and then after we
create the test set then we'll use the
model for inference on it all right so
we are back in our Jupiter notebook and
now we're going to go through the
process of creating the test set and
actually if you just glanced at this
code here you can see that this whole
process of setting up the samples and
labels lists and then generating the
data from the imagined clinical trial
that we discussed in a previous episode
we're then taking that generated data
and putting it into numpy array format
then shuffling that data and then
scaling the data to be on a scale from 0
to 1 rather than from the scale of 13 to
100 so actually that is the same exact
process using almost the same exact code
except for we're working with our tests
labels and test samples variables rather
than train labels and train samples so
we're not going to go line by line
through this code if you need a
refresher go check out the earlier
episode where we did the exact same
process for the training set the
important thing to take from this
process though is that the test set
should be prepared and processed in the
same format as the training data was so
we'll just go ahead and run the cells to
test and/or to create and process the
test data and now we are going to use
our model to predict on the test data so
to obtain predictions from our model we
call predict on the model that we
created in the last couple of episodes
so we are calling model dot predict and
we are first passing in this parameter X
which we're setting equal to our
test samples so that is what we created
in just the line above where we scaled
our test samples to be on a scale from
zero to one so this is the data that we
want our model to predict on then we
specify the batch size and we are
setting the batch size equal to ten
which is the exact same batch size that
we use for our training data whenever we
train the model as well and then the
last parameter we're specifying is this
verbose parameter we're setting this
equal to zero
because during predicting it there is
not any output from this function that
we actually care about seeing or that
it's going to be any use to us at the
moment so we're setting that equal to
zero to get no output all right so then
if we run this cell then our model
predicts on all of the data in our test
set and if we want to have a
visualization of what each of these
predictions from the model looks like
for each sample we can print them out
here so looking at these predictions the
way that we can interpret this is for
each element within our test set so for
each sample in our test set we are
getting a probability that map's to
either the patient not experiencing a
side effect or the patient experiencing
a side effect so for the first sample in
our test set this prediction says that
the model is 92 or is assigning a 92
percent probability to this patient not
experiencing a side effect and just a
around 8 percent probability of the
patient experiencing a side effect so
recall that we said no side effect
experience was labeled as a 0 and a side
effect experience was labeled as a 1 so
that is how we know that this particular
probability maps to not having a side
effect because it's in the 0th index and
this specific probability maps to having
a side effect because it is in the first
index so if we're interested in seeing
only the most probable prediction for
each sample in the test set then we can
run this cell here which is taking the
predictions
getting the index of the prediction with
the highest probability and if we print
that out then we can see that these are
a little bit easier to interpret than
the previous output so we can see for
the first sample that the prediction is
a zero the second sample is a one and
just to confirm if we go back up here we
can see that the first sample and bead
has the higher probability of a label of
zero meaning those side effects and the
second sample has a higher probability
of one meaning that the patient did
experience a side effect
so from these prediction results were
able to actually see the underlying
predictions but we're not able to make
much sense of them in terms of how well
the model did at these predictions
because we didn't supply the labels to
the model during inference in the same
way that we do during training this is
the nature of inference a lot of times
inference is occurring once the model
has been deployed to production so we
don't necessarily have correct labels
for the data that the model is inferring
from if we do have corresponding labels
for our test set though which in our
case we do because we are the ones who
generated the test data then we can
visualize the prediction results by
plotting them to a confusion matrix and
that will give us an overall idea at how
accurate our model was at inferring on
the test data we'll see exactly how
that's done in the next episode be sure
to check out the blog and other
resources available for this episode on
V + ur calm as well as the depot's
archive mind where you can gain access
to exclusive perks and rewards thanks
for contributing to collective
intelligence now let's move on to the
next episode
hey I'm Mandy from deep lizard in this
episode we'll demonstrate how to use a
confusion matrix to visualize prediction
results from a neural network during
inference
[Music]
in the last episode we showed how we
could use our trade model for inference
on data contained in a test set although
we have the labels for this test set
we don't pass them to the model during
inference and so we don't get any type
of accuracy readings for how well the
model does on the test set using a
confusion matrix we can visually observe
how well a model predicts on test data
let's jump right into the code to see
exactly how this is done we'll be using
scikit-learn to create our confusion
matrix so the first thing we need to do
is import the necessary packages that
we'll be making use of next we create
our confusion matrix by calling this
confusion matrix function from
scikit-learn and we pass in our test
labels as the true labels and we pass in
our predictions as the predictions and
that the confusion matrix its specs and
we call this rounded predictions
variable as well as the test labels
these were created in the last episode
so rounded predictions recall was when
we use the Arg max function to select
only the most probable prediction so now
our predictions are in this format and
then our labels are zeros and ones that
correspond to whether or not a patient
had side-effects or not so next we have
this plot confusion matrix function and
this is directly copied from
scikit-learn website there's a link to
the site on the corresponding blog where
you can copy this exact function but
this is just a function that
scikit-learn has created to be able to
easily plot in our notebook the
confusion matrix which is going to be
the actual visual output that we want to
see so we just run this cell to define
that function and now we create this
list that has the labels that we will
use on our confusion matrix so we want
the labels of no side-effects and had
side-effects those are the corresponding
labels for our test data then we're
going to call the plot confusion matrix
function that we just brought in and
defined above from side
learn and to that we are going to pass
in our confusion matrix and the classes
for the confusion matrix which we are
specifying see and plot labels which we
define just right above and lastly just
the title that is going to be the title
to display above the confusion matrix so
if we run this then we actually get the
confusion matrix plot alright so we have
our predicted labels on the x-axis and
our true labels on the y-axis so the way
we can read this is that we look and we
see that our model predicted that a
patient had no side effects ten times
when the patient actually had a side
effect so that's incorrect predictions
on the flip side though the model
predicted that the patient had no side
effects
196 times that the patient indeed had no
side effects so the this is the correct
predictions and actually generally
reading the confusion matrix looking at
the top left to the bottom right
diagonal these squares here in blue
going across the diagonal are the
correct predictions so we can see total
that the model predicted 200 plus 196 so
396 correct predictions out of a total
of 420 I think yes so all these numbers
added up equal 420 396 out of 420
predictions were correct so that gives
us about a 94% accuracy rate on our test
set which is equivalent to what we were
seeing for our validation accuracy rate
during training so as you can see a
confusion matrix is a great tool to use
to be able to visualize how well our
model is doing at its predictions and
also be able to drill in a little bit
further to see for which classes it
might need some work be sure to check
out the blog and other resources
available for this episode on V plus or
calm as well as the depot's archive mind
where you can gain access to exclusive
perks and rewards thanks for
contributing to collective intelligence
now let's move on to the next episode
hey I'm Mandy from deep lizard in this
episode we'll demonstrate the multiple
ways that we can save and load a Karass
sequential model we have a few different
options when it comes to saving and
loading a Karass sequential model and
these all work a little bit differently
from one another so we're going to go
through all of the options now we've
been working with a single model over
the last few episodes and we're going to
continue working with that one now I've
printed out a summary of that model to
refresh your memory about which one
we've been working with but just make
sure that in your Jupiter notebook that
you have that model already created
because we're going to now show how we
can save that model all right so the
first way to save a model is just by
calling the save function on it so to
save we pass in a path for which we want
to save our model and then the model
name or the file name that we want to
save our model under with the h5
extension so this h5 file is going to be
where the model is stored and this code
here is just a condition that I'm
checking to see if the models not
already saved to disk first then save it
because I don't want to continue saving
the model over and over again on my
machine if it's already been saved so
that's what this this condition is about
but this model dot save function is the
first way that we can save the model now
when we save you thing this way it saves
the architecture of the model allowing
us to be able to recreate it with the
same number of learner Bowl parameters
and layers and nodes etc it also saves
the weights of the model so if the
models already been trained then the
weights that it has learned and
optimized for are going to be in place
within this saved model on disk it also
saves the training configuration so
things like our loss and our optimizer
that we set whenever we compiled the
model and the state of the optimizer is
also saved so that allows us if we are
training the model and then we stop and
save the model to disk then we can later
load that model again and
training where we left off because the
state of the optimizer will be in that
saved state so this is the most
comprehensive option when it comes to
saving the model because it saves
everything the architecture the learning
both parameters and the state of the
model where it left off with training so
if we want to load a model later that we
previously saved to disk then we need to
first import this load model function
from tensorflow carousel models and then
we create a variable in this case I'm
calling it a new model and then setting
it to load model and then pointing to
where our saved model is on disk so then
if we run that and then look at a
summary of our new model we can see
indeed it is an exact replica in terms
of its architecture as the original
model up here that we had previously
saved to disk also we can look at the
weights of the new model we didn't look
at the weights ahead of time to be able
to compare them directly but this is
showing you that you can inspect the
weights to look and comparatively see
that the weights are actually the same
as the previous models weights if you
were to have taken a look at those
beforehand we can also look at the
optimizer just to show you that although
we never set an optimizer explicitly for
our new model because we are loading it
from the saved model it does indeed use
the atom optimizer that we set a while
back whenever we compiled our model for
training all right so that's it for the
first saving and loading option and
again that is the most comprehensive
option to save and load everything about
a particular model the next option that
we'll look at is using this function
called to JSON so we call model to JSON
if we only need to save the architecture
of the model so we don't want to set its
weight or the training configuration
then we can just save the model
architecture by saving it to a JSON
string so I'm using this example here
creating a variable called JSON string
setting it equal to model dot to JSON
remember model is our original model
that we've been working with so far up
to this point so we call to JSON and now
if we print out this JSON string then we
can see we get this string of details
about the model architecture so it's a
sequential model and then it's got the
layers organized with the individual
dense layers and all the details about
those specific layers from our original
model now if at a later point we want to
create a new model with our older models
architecture then if we saved it to a
JSON string then we can import the model
from JSON function from tensorflow
carousel models and now we're creating a
new variable called model architecture
and we are loading in the JSON string
using the model from JSON function so
now we have this new model which I'm
just calling model architecture and if
we look at the summary of that then
again we can see that this is identical
to the summary of the original model so
we have a new model in place now but we
only have the architecture in place so
you would have to retrain it to update
its weights and we would need to compile
it to get an optimizer and our loss and
everything like that defined this only
creates the model from an architecture
standpoint before moving on to our third
option I just wanted to mention a brief
point that we can go through this same
exact process but using a Hamel string
instead of a JSON string so the function
to create a gamal string is just model
dot to a Gamal instead of to JSON and
then the function to load a Gamal string
is model from a gamma model from a yamo
instead of model from JSON all right so
our next option to save a model is
actually just to save the weights of a
model so if you only need to save the
weights and you don't need to save the
architecture nor any of the training
configurations like the optimizer or
lost then we can save
soli and models weights by using the
save weights function so to do that we
just call model dot save weights and
this looks exactly the same as when we
called model dot save we're just passing
a path on disk to where to save our
model along with the file name ending
with an H v extension so I'm calling
this my model weights H 5 and again we
have this condition here where I'm just
checking if this H 5 file has already
been saved to disk otherwise I'm not
going to keep saving it over and over
again now the thing with this is that
when we save only the weights if we want
to load them at a later time then we
don't have a model already in place
because we didn't save the model itself
we only save the weights so to be able
to bring in our weights to a new model
then we would then need to create a
second model at that point with the same
architecture and then we could load the
weights in so that's what we're doing in
this cell I'm defining this model called
model 2 and it is the exact same model
from an architecture standpoint as the
first model so if we run this then at
that point we have the option to load
weights into this model and the shape of
these weights is going to have to match
the shape of what this model
architecture is essentially so we
couldn't have a model with five layers
here to find for example and load these
weights in because there wouldn't be a
direct mapping of where these particular
weights should be loaded so that's why
we have the same exact architecture here
as our original model so to load our
weights we call load weights and we
point to the place on disk where our
weights are saved and then we can call
get weights on our new model and see
that our new model has been populated
with weights from our original model all
right so now you know all the ways that
we can say various aspects of a Karass
sequential model be sure to check out
the blog and other resources available
for this episode on beep lizard comm as
well as the depot's archive mind where
you can gain access to exclusive perks
and rewards thanks for contributing to
collective intelligence now let's move
on to the
next episode hey I'm Andy from deep
lizard in this episode we'll go through
all the necessary image preparation and
processing steps needed to train our
first convolutional neural network our
goal over the next few episodes will be
to build and train a convolutional
neural network that can classify images
as cats or dogs the first thing that we
need to do is get and prepare our data
set for which we'll be training our
model we're going to work with the data
set from the cackle cats vs. dogs
competition and you can find a link to
download the data set in the
corresponding blog for this episode on V
Blizzard comm so we're mostly going to
organize our data on disk
programmatically but there's a couple of
manual steps that we'll go through first
so after you've downloaded the data set
from cackled you will have this zip
folder here and if we look inside then
this is the contents we have a zipped
train folder and a zipped test folder
along with this sample submission CSV so
we actually are not going to be working
with this or this so you can delete the
test zip as well as the CSV file we're
going to only be working with this train
zip so we want to extract the high-level
cats vs. or dogs vs. cats at first and
then extract the train zip so because
that takes a while I went ahead and did
that here so now I have just this train
directory because I moved the test
directory elsewhere and deleted the CSV
file so now I have this extracted train
folder and I go in here and I have a
nested train folder as you can see I'm
already in train once now I'm in train
again and in here we have all of these
images of cats and dogs okay
so that is the way that the data will
come downloaded the first step the next
step that we need to do now is to come
into here and grab all of these images
and we're going to control X or
cut all of these and bring them up to
the first train directory so we don't
want this nested directory structure
instead we're going to place them
directly within the first train
directory all right now all of our
images have been copied into our base
train directory here so this nested
train directory that the images
previously belong to is now empty so we
can just go ahead and delete this one
all right so now our directory structure
is just this dogs vs. cat top directory
within we have a train directory and
then we have all of the images within
our train directory both of cats and
dogs the last step is to just move the
dogs versus cats directory that has all
the data in it to be in the place on
disk where you're going to be working so
for me I am in relative to my Jupiter
notebook I am within a directory called
data and I have placed dogs vs. cats
here all right so that's it for the
manual labor now everything else that
we'll do to organize the data and then
later process the data will be
programmatically through code all right
so we're now here within our Jupiter
notebook and first things first we need
to import all of the packages that we'll
be making use of and all the packages
here are not just for this specific
episode on processing the image data but
actually these are all of the packages
that we'll be making use of over the
next several episodes as we're working
with CNN's all right so we'll get that
taken care of and now just this cell
here is making sure if we are using a
GPU that tensorflow is able to identify
it correctly and we are in an enabling
memory growth on the GPU as well if
you're not using a GPU then no worries
as mentioned earlier you are completely
fine to follow this course with a CPU
only alright so now we're going to pick
back up with organizing our data on disk
so assuming that we've gone through the
first steps from the beginning of this
episode we're now going to organize the
data into trained valid and test ders
which correspond to our training
validation and test sets
so this script here is going to
first change directories into our dog vs
cat directory and then it's going to
check to make sure that the directory
structure that we're about to make does
not already exist and if it doesn't it's
going to proceed with the rest of this
script so the first thing that it's
doing as long as the directory structure
is not already in place is making the
following directories so we already have
a train directory so it's going to make
a nested dog and cat directory within
train and then additionally it's going
to make a valid directory that contains
dog and cat directories and a test
directory which also contains dog and
cat directories
now this particular data set contains
twenty five thousand images of dogs and
cats and that is pretty much overkill
for the test that we will be using these
images for in the upcoming episodes
we're actually only going to use a small
subset of this data you're free to work
with all the data if you'd like but it
would take a lot longer to train our
networks and work with the data in
general if we were using the entire set
of it so we are going to be working with
a subset consisting of 1,000 images in
our training set 200 in our validation
set and 100 in our test set and each of
those sets are going to be split evenly
among cats and dogs so that's exactly
what this block of code here is doing
it's going into the images that are in
our dog vs cat directory and moving 500
randomly moving 500 cat images into our
trained cat directory 500 dog images
into our trained dog directory and then
similarly doing the same thing for our
valid are valid validation set both for
cat and dogs and then our test set both
for cat and dogs with just these
quantities differing regarding the
amounts that I stated earlier for each
of the sets and we're able to understand
which images are cats and which are dogs
based on the names of the files so if
you saw earlier the cat images actually
had the word
cat in the file names and then the dog
images had the word dog in the file
names so that's how we're able to select
dog images and cat images here with this
script alright so after this script runs
we can pull up our file explorer and
look at the directory structure and make
sure it is what we expect so we have our
dog versus cat directory within our data
directory here so if we enter then we
have test trained and valid directories
inside test we have cat that has cat
images and inside dog we have dog images
if we back out and go to train we can
see similarly and if we go into valid we
can see similarly and you can select one
of the folders and look at the
properties too to see how many files
exist within the directory to make sure
that is it is the amount that we chose
to put in from our script and that we
didn't accidentally make any type of
error so if we go back to the dog
sources cats the root directory here you
can see we have all of these cat and dog
images left over these were the
remaining 23 thousand or so that were
left over after we moved our subset into
our trained valid and test directories
so you're free to make use of these in
any way that you want or delete them or
move them to another location all of
what we'll be working with are in these
three directories here all right so at
this point we have obtained the data and
we have organized the data now it's time
to move on to processing the data so if
we scroll down first we are just
creating these variables here where we
have assigned our trained valid and test
paths so this is just pointing to the
location on disk where our different
data sets reside now recall earlier in
the course we talked about that whenever
we train a model that we need to put the
data into a format that the model
expects and we know that when we train a
Karass sequential model that the model
receives the data whenever we call the
fit function so we are going to put our
image
into the format of a Karass generator
and we're doing that in this cell here
we're creating these trained valid and
test batches and setting them equal to
image data generator dot flow from
directory which is going to return a
directory iterator basically it's going
to create batches of data from the
directories where our data sets aside
and these batches of data will be able
to be passed to the sequential model
using the fit function so now let's look
exactly at how we are defining these
variables so let's focus just on train
batches for now so we're setting train
batches equal to image data generator
dot flow from directory but first to
image data generator we are specifying
this pre-processing function and setting
that equal to TF Kerris applications bgg
16 dot pre process input so I'm just
going to tell you for now that this is a
function that is going to apply some
type of pre-processing on the images
before they get passed to the network
that we'll be using and we're processing
them in such a way that is equivalent to
the way that a very popular model known
as BG 16 we're processing our images in
the same format as which images that get
passed to this vgg 16 model our process
and we're going to talk about more about
this in a future episode so don't let it
confuse you now just know that this is
causing some type of processing to occur
all in our images and we'll talk more
about it in a future episode and not
stress on it now because it's not
necessarily very important for us right
at this moment the technical details of
that at least so besides that when we
call flow from directory this is where
we are passing in our actual data and
specifying how we want this data to be
processed so we are setting the
directory equal to train path which up
here we defined the location on disk
where our training set was under the
Train path variable and then we're
setting
getsize equal to 224 by 224 so this is
the height and width that we want the
cat and dog images to be resized to so
if you're working with an image data set
that has images of varying sizes or you
just want to scale them up or scale them
down it this is how you can specify that
to happen and this will resize all
images in your data set to be of this
heightened with before passing them to
our network now we are specifying our
classes which are just the classes for
the potential labels of our data set so
cat or dog and we are setting our batch
size to ten we do the exact same thing
for the validation set and the test set
everything is the exact same for both of
them except for where each of these sets
live on disk as being specified here
under the directory parameter and then
the only other difference is here for
our test batches we are specifying this
shuffle equals false parameter now this
is because whenever we use our test
batches later for inference to get our
model to predict on images of cats and
dogs after training and validation has
been completed we're going to want to
look at our prediction results in a
confusion matrix like we did in a
previous video for a separate data set
and in order to do that we need to be
able to access the unshelled labels for
our test set so that's all we set
shuffle equals false for only this set
for both validation and training sets we
do want the data sets to be shuffled all
right so we run this and we get the
output of found at 1,000 images
belonging to two classes and that is
corresponding to our train batches found
200 images belonging to two classes
which corresponds to valid batches and
then the 100 belonging to two classes
corresponding to our test batches so
that is the output that you want to see
for yourself
that's letting you know that it found
the images on disk that belong to both
the cat and dog classes that you have
specified here so if you are not getting
this at this point if you
found zero images then perhaps you're
pointing to the wrong place on disk you
just need to make sure that it's able to
find all the images that you set up
previously all right and here we are
just verifying that that is indeed the
case now next we are going to just grab
a single batch of images and the
corresponding labels from our train
batches and remember our batch size is
10 so this should be 10 images along
with the 10 corresponding labels next
we're introducing this function plot
images that we're going to use to plot
the images from our train batches that
we just obtained above and this function
is directly from tensor flows website so
check the link in the corresponding blog
for this episode on D poster comm to see
to be able to get to the tensor flows
site where exactly I pulled this off of
so we will define this function here
alright so now we're just going to use
this function to plot our images from
our test batches here and we're going to
print the corresponding labels for those
images so if we scroll down we can see
this is what a batch of training data
looks like so this might be a little bit
different than what you expected given
the fact that it looks like the color
data has been a little bit distorted and
that's due to the pre-processing
function that we called to pre-process
the images in such a way that in the
same type of way that images get pre
processed for the famous vgg 16 model so
like I said we're going to discuss in
detail what exactly that pre processing
function is doing technically as well as
why we're using it in a later video but
for now just know that it's skewing the
RGB data in some way so we can still
make out the fact that this is a cat and
this looks like a cat this is a dog dog
dog dog cat yes so we can still kind of
generally make out what these images are
but the color data is skewed but don't
worry too much about the technical
details behind that for right now just
know that this is what the data looks
like before we pass it to the model and
here are the corresponding labels for
the data so we have these one hot
encoded vectors that represent either
cat or dog so a one zero represents a
cat and a zero one represents a dog ok
so I guess I was wrong earlier with
thinking that this one was the dog this
one is a cat because as we can see it
maps to the one zero one hunting and if
you don't know what I mean by one hot
encoding then check out the
corresponding video for that in the deep
learning fundamentals course on beep
lasercom but yet we can see that 0 1 is
the vector used to represent the label
of a dog so this one's a dog and the
next two are dogs as well this one and
this one now just a quick note about
everything that we've discussed up to
this point sometimes we do not have the
corresponding labels for our test set so
in the examples that we've done so far
in this course we've always had the
corresponding labels for our test set
but in practice a lot of times you may
not have those labels and in fact if we
were to have used the downloaded test
directory that came from the cackled
download then we would see that that
test directory does not have the images
labeled with cat or dog so in this case
we do have the test labels for the cat
and dog images since we pulled them from
the original training set from catechol
that did have the corresponding labels
but if you don't have access to the test
labels and you are wondering how to
process your test data accordingly then
check the blog for this episode on the
poster comm I have a section there that
demonstrates what you need to do
differently from what we showed in this
video if you do not have access to the
labels for your test set alright so now
we have obtained our image data organize
it on disk and processed it accordingly
for our convolutional neural network so
now in the next episode we are going to
get set up to start building and
training our first CNN be sure to check
out the blog and other resources
available for this episode on veep
lizard comm
as well as the depot's art I've mind
where you can gain access to exclusive
perks and rewards thanks for
contributing to collective intelligence
now let's move on to the next episode
hey I'm Mandy from deep lizard
in this episode we'll demonstrate how to
build a convolutional neural network and
then train it on images of cats and dogs
using tensor flows integrated Kerris API
[Music]
we'll be continuing to work with the cat
and dog image data that we created in
the last episode so make sure you still
have all of that in place as well as the
imports that we brought in in the last
episode as well as we'll be making use
of those imports over the next several
videos of working with CNN's so to
create our first CNN we will be making
use of the Charis sequential model and
recall we introduced this model in an
earlier episode when we were working
with just plain simple and numerical
data but we'll continue to work with
this model here with our first CNN so
the first layer to this model that we
pass is a comp 2d layer so this is just
our standard convolutional layer that
will accept image data and to this layer
we're arbitrarily setting the filter
value equal to 32
so this first convolutional layer will
have 32 filters with a kernel size of
3x3 so the choice of 32 is pretty
arbitrary but the kernel size of 3x3 is
a very common choice for image data now
this first column 2d layer will be
followed by the popular lu activation
function and we are specifying padding
equals same here and this just means
that our images will have zero padding
padding the outside so that the
dimensionality of the images aren't
reduced after the convolution operations
so lastly for our first layer only we
specify the input shape of the data and
we're call we touched on this parameter
previously you can think of this as kind
of creating an implicit input layer for
our model this comp 2d is actually our
first hidden layer
the input layer is made up of the input
data itself and so we just need to tell
the model the shape of the input data
which in our case is going to be 224 by
224 recall we saw that we were setting
that target size parameter to 224 by 224
whenever we created our valid test and
train directory iterators we said that
we wanted our images to be of this
height and width and then this 3 here is
regarding the color channels since these
cut since these images are in RGB format
we have three color channels so we
specified this input shape so then we
follow our first convolutional layer
with a max pooling layer where we're
setting our pool size to 2 by 2 and our
strides by 2 and if you are familiar
with max fulling then you know this is
going to cut our image dimensions in
half so if you need to know more about
max pooling or you just need a refresher
same thing with padding here for zero
padding activation functions anything
like that then be sure to check those
episodes out in the corresponding deep
learning fundamentals course on D poster
comm so after this max pooling layer
were then adding another convolutional
layer that looks pretty much exactly the
same as the first one except for 4 we're
not including the input shape parameter
since we only specify that for our first
hidden layer and we are specifying the
filters to be 64 here instead of 32 so
64 is again an arbitrary choice I just
chose that number here but the general
rule of increasing functions as you go
until later layers of the network is
common practice we then follow this
second convolutional layer with another
max pooling layer identical to the first
one then we flatten all of this into a
one-dimensional tensor before passing it
to our dense output layer which only has
two nodes corresponding to cat and dog
and our output layer is being followed
by the softmax after activation function
which as you know is going to give us
probabilities for each corresponding
output
from the model alright so if we run this
we can then check out the summary of our
model and this is what we have exactly
what we built along with some additional
details about the learner Bowl
parameters and the output shape of the
network so these are things that are
also covered in the in the deep learning
fundamentals course as well if you want
to check out more information about
learn about parameters and such so now
that our model is built we can prepare
it for training by calling model dot
compiled which again we have already
used in a previous episode when we were
just training on numerical data but as
you will see here it looks pretty much
the same as before we are setting our
optimizer equal to the atom optimizer
with a learning rate of 0.0001 and we
are using categorical cross entropy and
we are looking at the accuracy as our
metrics to be able to judge the model
performance just a quick note before
moving on we are using categorical cross
entropy but since we have just two
outputs from our model either cat or dog
then it is possible to instead use
binary cross entropy and if we did that
then we would need to just have a 1 at
single output node from our model
instead of 2 and then rather than
following our output layer with the
softmax activation function we would
need to follow it with sigmoid and both
of these approaches using categorical
cross entropy loss with the setup that
we have here or using binary cross
entropy loss with the setup that I just
described work equally well they're
totally equivalent and will yield the
same results categorical cross entropy
and using soft max on the act as the
activation function for the output layer
are just a common approach for when you
have more than two classes so I like to
continue using that approach even when I
only have two classes just because it's
general and it's the case that we're
going to use whenever there's more than
two classes anyway so I just like to
stick with using the same type of setup
even when we only have two outputs
alright so after compiling our model we
can now train it using model dot fit
which we should be very familiar
up to this point so to the fit function
we are first specifying our training
data which is stored in trained batches
and then we specify our validation data
which is stored in valid batches recall
this is a different way of creating
validation data as we spoke about in an
earlier episode we're not using
validation split here because we've
actually created a validation set
separately ourselves before fitting the
model so we are specifying that
separated set here as the validation
data parameter then we are setting our
epochs equal to 10 so we're only going
to train for 10 runs this time and
setting verbose verbose equal to 2 so
that we can see the most verbose output
during training and one other thing to
mention is that you will see here that
we are specifying X just as we have in
the past but we are not specifying Y
which is our target data usually and
that's because when data is stored as a
generator as we have here the the
generator itself actually contains the
corresponding labels so we do not need
to specify them separately whenever we
call fit because they're actually
contained within the generator itself so
let's go ahead and run this now alright
so the model just finished training so
let's check out the results before we do
just if you get this warning it appears
from the research I've done to be a bug
within tensorflow that's supposed to be
fixed in a in the next release actually
is what I read so you can just safely
ignore this warning it has no impact on
our training but if we scroll down and
look at these results then we can see
that by our tenth epoch our accuracy on
our training set has reached 100% so
that is great but our validation
accuracy is here at 69% so not so great
we definitely see that we have some
overfitting going on here so if this was
a model that we really cared about and
that we really wanted to use and be able
to deploy to production then in this
scenario we would need to stop what
we're doing and combat this overfitting
problem before going further but what we
are going to do
is that we'll be seeing in an upcoming
episode how we can use a pre trained
model to perform really well on this
data and that'll get us exposed to the
concept of fine tuning before we do that
though we are going to see in the next
episode how this model holds up to
inference at predicting on images in our
test set be sure to check out the blog
and other resources available for this
episode on v+ or calm as well as the
depot's archive mind where you can gain
access to exclusive perks and rewards
thanks for contributing to collective
intelligence now let's move on to the
next episode hey I may be from deep
lizard in this episode will demonstrate
how to use a convolutional neural
network for inference to predict on
image data using tensor flows integrated
Kerris api last time we built and
trained our first CNN against cat and
dog image data and we saw that the
training results were great with the
model achieving 100% accuracy on the
training set however it lagged behind by
quite a good bit at only 70 percent
accuracy on our validation set so that
tells us that the model wasn't
generalizing as well as we hoped but
nonetheless we are going to use our
model now for inference to predict on
cat and dog images in our test set given
the less than decent results that we
solve from the validation performance
our expectation is that the model is not
going to do so well on the test set
either it's probably going to perform at
around the same 70 percent rate but this
is still going to give us exposure about
how we can use a CNN for inference using
the Charis sequential API alright so we
are back in our Jupiter notebook and we
need to make sure that we have all the
code in place from the last couple of
episodes as we will be continuing to
make it use of both our model that we
built last time as well as our test data
from whenever we prepared the datasets
so the first thing we're going to do is
get a batch of test data
from our test batches and then we're
going to plot that batch we're going to
plot the images specifically and then
we're going to print out the
corresponding labels for those images
and we're using before we do that just a
reminder this plot images function that
we introduced in the last couple of
episodes alright so if we scroll down we
have our test batches recall we have the
discussion about why the image data
looks the way that it does in terms of
the color being skewed last time but we
can see that just by looking even though
we have kind of distorted color we have
these are all actually cats here and by
looking at the corresponding label for
these images we can see that they are
all labeled with the one hot and coded
vector of one zero which we know is the
label for cat so if you're wondering why
we have all cats as our first ten images
in our first batch here that is because
recall whenever we created the test set
we specified that we did not want it to
be shuffled and that was so that we
could do the following if we come to our
next cell
and we run test batches classes then we
can get a array that has all of the
corresponding labels for each image in
the test set so given that we have
access to the unshelled labels for the
test set that's why we don't want to
shuffle the test set directly because we
want to be able to have this one one
direct mapping from the unshelled labels
to the test data set and if we were to
shuffle the test data set every time we
generated a batch then we wouldn't be
able to have the correct mapping between
labels and samples so we care about
having the correct mapping because later
after we get our predictions from the
model we're going to want to plot our
predictions to a confusion matrix and so
we want the corresponding labels that
belong to the samples in the test set
all right so next we're actually going
to go ahead and obtain our predictions
by calling model dot predict just as we
have in earlier episodes
or other datasets and 2x we are
specifying our test batches so all of
our test data set and we are choosing
verbose to be 0 to get no output
whenever we run our predictions so here
we are just printing out the rounded
predictions from the model so the way
that we can read this is first each one
of these arrays is a prediction for a
single sample so if we just look at the
first one this is the prediction for the
first sample and the test set so this
one wherever there is a one with each
prediction is the one is the index for
the output class that had the highest
probability from the model so in this
case we see that the 0th index had the
highest probability so we can just say
that the label that the model predicted
for this first sample was a zero because
we see that there is a 1 here in the 0th
index and if we look at the first
element or if we look at the first label
here up here for our first test sample
it is indeed a zero so we can eyeball
that and see that the model did
accurately predict all the way down to
here because that's the first 1 2 3 4 5
6 and 1 2 3 4 5 6 ok so but then
whenever we see that the model predicted
the first index to be the highest
probability that means that the problem
that the model predicted an output label
of a 1 and so that corresponds to dog so
it's hard for us to kind of draw an
overall conclusion about the prediction
accuracy for this test set just
eyeballing the results like this but if
we scroll down then we know that we have
the tool of a confusion matrix that we
can use to make visualizing these
results much easier like we've seen in
previous episodes of this course already
so we are going to do that now we're
going to create a confusion matrix using
it this can
you matrix function from scikit-learn
which we've already been introduced to
and we are passing in our true labels
using test batches classes recall that
we just touched on that a few minutes
ago and for our predicted labels we are
passing in the predictions from our
model we are getting the we're actually
passing in the index of each we're
actually using Arg max to pass in the
index of where the most probable
prediction was from our predictions list
so this is something that we've already
covered in previous episodes for why we
do that so if we run that we're now
going to bring in at this plot confusion
matrix which we've discussed is directly
from scikit-learn s-- website linked to
that is in the corresponding blog for
this episode on beefless or calm this is
just going to allow us to plot our
confusion matrix in a moment and now if
we look at the class indices we see that
cat is first and dog is second so we
just need to look at that so that we
understand in which order we should put
our plot labels for our confusion matrix
and next we call plot confusion matrix
and pass in the confusion matrix itself
as well as the labels for the confusion
matrix and a title for the entire matrix
so let's check that out all right so
from what we learned about how we can
easily interpret a confusion matrix we
know that we can just look at this
diagonal here running from top left to
bottom right to see what the model
predicted correctly so not that great
the model is definitely overfitting at
this point so like I said if this was
the model that we were really concerned
about then we would definitely want to
combat that overfitting problem but for
now we are going to move on to a new
model using a pre trained
state-of-the-art model called vgg
sixteen in the next episode so that we
can see how well that model does on
classifying images of cats and dogs be
sure to check out the blog and other
resources available for this episode on
beep lizard comm as well as the depot's
archive mind where you can gain access
to exclusive
perks and rewards thanks for
contributing to collective intelligence
now let's move on to the next episode
hey I may be from beef lizard in this
episode we'll demonstrate how we can
fine-tune a pre-trained model to
classify images using tensor flows Karis
API the pre trained model that we'll be
working with is called VG g16 and this
is the model that won the 2014 image net
competition in the image net competition
multiple teams compete against each
other to build a model that best
classifies images within the image net
library and the image net library is
made up of thousands of images that
belong to one thousand different classes
using Kerris we'll import this vgg 16
model and then fine tune it to not
classify on one of the 1000 categories
for which it was originally trained but
instead only on two categories cat and
dog note however that cats and dogs were
included in the original image net
library for which vgg 16 was trained on
and because of this we won't have to do
much tuning to change the model from
classifying from 1000 classes to just
the two cat and dog classes
so the overall fine-tuning that we'll do
will be very minimal in later episodes
though we'll do more involved
fine-tuning and use transfer learning to
transfer what a model has learned on an
original data set to completely new data
in a new custom data set that we'll be
using later to understand fine tuning
and transfer learning at a fundamental
level check out the corresponding
episode for fine tuning in the deep
learning fundamentals course on V
Blizzard comm before we actually start
building our model let's quickly talk
about the vgg 16 pre-processing that is
done now recall we are here in our
jupiter notebook this is from last time
when we plotted a batch from our test
data set and a few episodes ago we
discussed the fact that this color data
was skewed as a result of the vgg 16
processing function that we were calling
well now we're going to discuss what
exactly this pre-processing does so as
we can see we can still make out the
images as these here being all cats but
it's just the data the color data itself
that appears to be distorted so if we
look at the paper that the authors of
vgg 16b tell the model in under the
architecture section let's blow this up
a bit we can see that they state that
the only pre-processing we do is
subtract the mean RGB value computing on
the trait computed on the training set
from each pixel so what does that mean
that means that they computed the mean
red value pixel from all of the training
data and then once they had that mean
value across each image in the training
set they subtracted that mean value from
the red value the red pixel each pixel
in the image and then they did the same
thing for the green and blue pixel
values as well so they found the green
picks the mean green pixel value among
the entire training set and then for
each sample in the training set every
green pixel they subtracted that green
value from it so the same thing for the
blue of course so that's what they did
for the pre-processing so given that
that's how BG g16 was originally trained
that means now whenever new data is
passed to the model that it needs to be
processed in the same exact way as the
original training set so Kerris already
has functions built in for popular
models like vgg 16 where they have that
pre-processing in place that matches for
the corresponding model so that's why we
were calling that model whenever we
process our cat-and-dog images earlier
so that we could go ahead and get those
images processed in such a way that
matched how the original training set
was processed when vgg was originally
trained all right so that is what that
color distortion is all about so now
let's jump back into the code now that
we know what that's about we have an
understanding of the pre-processing
let's now get back to actually building
the fine-tuned model so the first thing
that we need to do is download the model
and when you call this for the first
time you will need an internet
connection because it's going to be
downloading the model from the internet
but after this is the subsequent calls
to this function will just be grabbing
this model from the downloaded copy on
your machine alright so the models been
downloaded now we are just running this
summary and we can see that this model
is much more complex than what we have
worked with up to this point so total
there are almost 140 million parameters
in this model and on disk it is over 500
megabytes so it is quite large now
recall I said that this vgg 16 model
originally was predicting for 1,000
different imagenet classes so here we
can see our output layer of the vgg 16
model has 1,000 different outputs so our
objective is going to simply be to
change this last output layer to predict
only two output classes corresponding to
cat and dog along with a couple other
details regarding the fine-tuning
process that we'll get to in just a
moment so now we're actually going to
just skip these two cells here these are
just for me to be able to make sure that
I've imported the model correctly but it
is not relevant for any code here it's
just checking that the trainable
parameters and non trainable parameters
are what I expect them to be after
importing but this is not of concern at
the moment for us so if we scroll down
here we're now going to build a new
model called sequential all right now
before we run this code we're actually
just going to look at the type of model
das's so this is returning a model
called model so this is actually a model
from the Charis functional API we have
been previously working with sequential
models so we are in a late
episode going to discuss the functional
API in depth it's a bit more complicated
and more sophisticated than the
sequential model for now since we're not
ready to bring in the functional model
yet we are going to convert the original
vgg 16 model into a sequential model and
we're going to do that by creating a new
variable called model here and setting
this equal to an instance of sequential
object and we are going to then loop
through every layer in vgg 16 except for
the last output layer we're leaving that
out we're going to loop through every
layer and then add each layer into our
new sequential model so now we'll look
at a summary of our new model and by
looking at this summary if you take the
time to compare the previous summary to
this summary what you will notice is
that they are exactly the same except
for the last layer has been not included
in this new model so this layer here we
have this fully connected to layer as
what this is here with the output shape
4,096 here if we scroll back up we can
see that this is this layer here so the
predictions layer has not been included
because when we were iterating over our
for loop we went all the way up to the
second-to-last layer we did not include
the last layer of vgg 16 all right so
now let's scroll back down and we're now
going to iterate over all of the layers
within our new sequential model and we
are going to set each of these layers to
not be trainable by setting layer dot
trainable to false and what this is
going to do is going to freeze the
trainable parameters or the weights and
biases from all the layers in the model
so that they're not going to be
retrained whenever we go through the
training process for cats and dogs
because vgg 16 has already learned
features of cats and dogs in its
original training we don't
wanted to have to go through more
training again since it's already
learned those features so that's why we
are freezing the weights here we're now
going to add our own output layer to
this model so remember we've removed the
previous output layer that had ten
output Erb that had 1000 output classes
rather and now we are going to add our
own output layer that has only two
output classes for cat and dog so we add
that now since we have set all of the
previous layers to not be trainable we
can see that actually only our last
output layer that's going to be the only
trainable layer in the entire model and
like I said before that's because we
already know that vgg 16 has already
learned the features of cats and dogs
during its original training so we only
need to retrain this output layer to
classify to output classes so now if we
look at a new summary of our model then
we'll see that everything is the same
except for now we have this new dense
layer as our output layer which only has
two classes instead of 1000 from the
original vgg 16 model we can also see
that our model now only has 8,000
trainable parameters and those are all
within our output layer as I said that
our output layer is our only trainable
layer so before actually all of our
layers are trainable if we go take a
look at our original vgg 16 model we see
that we have 138 million total
parameters all of which are trainable
none of which are non trainable so if we
didn't freeze those layers and then they
would be getting retrained during the
training process for our cat and dog
images so just to scroll back down again
and check this out
we can see that now we still have quite
a bit of learn Bowl parameter or of
total parameters 134 million but only
8,000 of which are trainable
the rest are non trainable in the next
episode we'll see how we can train this
modified model on our images of cats and
dogs be sure to check out the blog and
other resources available for this
episode
on beep laser calm as well as the deep
alert I've mind where you can gain
access to exclusive perks and rewards
thanks for contributing to collective
intelligence now let's move on to the
next episode
hey I'm Mandy from V blizzard in this
episode we'll demonstrate how to train
the fine-tuned vgg 16 model that we
built last time on our own data set of
cats and dogs all right so we're jumping
straight into the code to train our
model but of course be sure that you
already have the code in place from last
time as we will be building on the code
that we have already run previously so
we are using our model here to first
compile it to get it ready for training
this model is the sequential model that
we built last time that is our
fine-tuned vgg 16 model containing all
the same layers with frozen weights
except for our last layer which we have
modified to output only two possible
outputs so we are compiling this model
using the atom optimizer as we have
previously used with the learning rate
of 0.0001 and a the loss we are using
again categorical cross entropy just
like we have before and we are using the
accuracy as our only metric to judge
model performance so there is nothing
new here with this call to compile it is
pretty much exactly the same as what we
have seen for our previous models now we
are going to train the model using model
dot fit and we are passing in our
training data set which we have stored
in train batches we are passing in our
validation set which we have stored as
valid batches and we are only going to
run this model for 5 epochs and we are
setting the verbosity level to 2 so that
we can see the most comprehensive output
from the model during training so let's
see what happens
alright so training has just finished
and we have some pretty outstanding
results
so just after five a pox on our training
data and validation data we have an
accuracy on our trading data of 99
percent and validation accuracy right on
par at 98 percent so that's just after
five a box and if we look at the first
epoch even our first epoch gives it
gives us a training accuracy of eighty
five percent just starting out and a
validation accuracy of ninety-three
percent so this isn't totally surprising
because remember earlier in the course
we discussed how vgg sixteen had already
been trained on images of cats and dogs
from the imagenet library so it had
already learned those features now the
slight training that we're doing on the
output layer is just to Train vgg
sixteen to output only cat or dog
classes and so it's really not
surprising that it's doing such a good
job right off the bat in its first epoch
and even it and even considerably better
in its fifth epoch at 99% training
accuracy now we're called the previous
CNN that we built from scratch ourselves
the really simple convolutional neural
network that model actually did really
well on the training data reaching 100%
accuracy after a small amount of epochs
as well where we saw it lagging though
was with the validation accuracy so it
had a validation accuracy of around 70
percent here we see that we are at 98%
so the main recognizable difference
between a very simple CNN and this vgg
16 fine-tune model is how well this
model generalizes to our cat and dog
data and the validation set whereas the
model we built from scratch did not
generalize so well on data that was not
included in the training set in the next
episode we're going to use this vgg 16
model for inference to predict on the
cat and dog images in our test set and
given the accuracy that we are seeing on
the validation set here we should expect
to see some really good results on our
test set as well be sure to check out
the blog and other resources available
for this episode on beep laser comm as
well as the depot's archive mind where
you can gain access to exclusive
perks and rewards thanks for
contributing to collective intelligence
now let's move on to the next episode
hey I'm Mandy from deep lizard
in this episode we'll use our fine-tuned
vgg 16 model for inference to predict on
images in our test set alright we are
jumping right back into our Jupiter
notebook again making sure that all the
code is in place and has run it from the
previous episodes as we will be building
on the code that has been run there so
first things first is that we are going
to be using the model to get predictions
from our test set so to do that we call
model dot predict which we have been
exposed to in the past recall that this
model here is our fine-tuned vgg 16
model and to predict we are passing our
test set which we have stored in test
batches and we are setting our verbosity
level to zero as we do not want to see
any output any output from our
predictions now recall previously we
talked about how we did not shuffle the
test set for our cat and dog image data
set and that is because we want to be
able to access the classes here in an
unshelled order so that we can then pass
in the unshelled classes that correspond
to the well sorry the unshelled labels
that correspond to the unshelled test
data we want to be able to have those in
a one-to-one mapping where the labels
actually are the correct on shuffled
labels for the unshelled data samples we
want to be able to pass those to our
confusion matrix so this is the same
story as we saw whenever we were using
our CNN that we built from scratch a few
episodes back we did this same process
we're using the same data set recall and
so now we are plotting this confusion
matrix in the exact same manner as
before so this is actually the exact
same line that we used to plot the
confusion matrix a few episodes back
when we plotted
on this same exact test set for the CNN
that we built from scratch and just a
reminder from last time recall that we
looked at the class indices of the test
batches so that we could get the correct
order of our cat and dog classes to use
for our labels for our confusion matrix
so we are again doing the same thing
here and now we are calling the
scikit-learn plot confusion matrix which
you should have defined earlier in your
notebook from a previous episode and to
plot confusion matrix we are passing in
our confusion matrix and our labels
defined just above as well as a general
title for the confusion matrix itself so
now let's check out the plot so that we
can see how well our model did on these
predictions so this is what the third or
fourth time that we've used a confusion
matrix in this course so far so you
should be pretty normalized to how to
read this data so recall the quick and
easy way is to look from the top left to
the bottom right along this diagonal and
we can get a quick overview of how well
the model did so the model correctly
predicted a dog for forty nine times
four images that were truly dogs and it
correctly predicted a cat forty seven
times four images that truly were cats
so we can see that one time it predicted
a cat when it was actually a dog and
three times it predicted a dog when
images were actually cats
so overall the model incorrectly
predicted four samples so that gives us
96 out of 100 correct or let's see 96
correct predictions out of 100 total
predictions so that gives us an accuracy
rate on our test set of 96% not
surprising given what we saw in the last
episode for the high level of accuracy
that our model had on the validation set
so overall this fine-tuned vgg 16 model
does really well at generalizing on data
that it had not seen during training a
lot better than our
model for which we built from scratch
now recall that we previously discussed
that the overall fine-tuning approach
that we took to this model was pretty
minimal
since cat-and-dog data was already
included in the original training set
for the original vgg 16 model but in
upcoming episodes we are going to be
doing more fine-tuning more fine-tuning
than what we saw here for vgg 16 as we
will be fine-tuning another well-known
pre-trained model but this time for a
completely new data set that was not
included in the original data set that
it was trained on so stay tuned for that
be sure to check out the blog and other
resources available for this episode on
deep lizard comm as well as the depot's
archive mind where you can gain access
to exclusive perks and rewards thanks
for contributing to collective
intelligence now let's move on to the
next episode
hey I'm Mandy from deep lizard in this
episode we'll introduce mobile nets a
class of a lightweight deep
convolutional neural networks that are
much smaller and faster in size than
many of the mainstream popular models
that are really well known
[Music]
mobile nets are a class of small
low-power low latency models that can be
used for things like classification
detection and other things that CN NS
are typically good for and because of
their small size these models are
considered great for mobile devices
hence the name mobile nets so I have
some stats taken down here so just to
give a quick comparison in regards to
size the size of the full VG g16 network
that we've worked with in the past few
episodes is about 553 megabytes on disk
so pretty large
generally speaking the size of one of
the currently largest mobile Nets is
only about 17 megabytes so that's a
pretty huge difference especially when
you think about deploying a model to run
on a mobile app for example this vast
size difference is due to the number of
parameters or weights and biases
contained in the model so for example
let's see vgg 16 as we saw previously
has about 138 million total parameters
so a lot and the 17 megabyte mobile net
that we talked about which was the
largest mobile necklace
so that is much much smaller on a
relative scale than vgg 16 with 138
million aside from the size on disk
being a consideration when it comes to
comparing mobile Nets to other larger
models we also need to consider the
memory as well so the more parameters
that a model has the more space in
memory it will be taking up also so
while mobile nets are faster and smaller
than the competitors of these big hefty
models like bgg 16 there is a catch or a
trade-off and that trade-off is accuracy
so mobile nets are not as accurate as
some of these big players like bgg 16
for example but don't let that
discourage you while it is true that
mobile nets aren't as accurate as these
resource heavy models like vgg 16 for
example
the trade-off is actually pretty small
with only a relatively small reduction
in accuracy and in the corresponding
blog for this episode I have a link to a
paper that goes more in depth to this
relatively small accuracy difference if
you'd like to check that out further
let's now see how we can work with
mobile nets and code with Karis alright
so we are in our Jupiter notebook and
the first thing we need to do is import
all of the packages that we will be
making use of which these are not only
for this video but for the next several
videos where we will be covering mobile
net and as I mentioned earlier in this
course a GPU is not required but if
you're running a GPU then you want to
run this cell this is the same cell that
we've seen a couple of times already in
this course earlier where we are just
making sure that tensorflow can identify
our GPU if we're running one and it is
setting the memory growth to true if we
do have a GPU so again don't worry if
you don't have a GPU don't worry but if
you do then run this cell similar to how
we downloaded the vgg 16 model when we
were working with it in previous
episodes we take that same approach to
download mobile net here so we call TF
cares the applications mobile metal net
and that the first time we call it is
going to download mobile net from the
internet so you need an internet
connection but subsequent calls to this
are just going to be getting the model
from a saved model on disk and loading
it into memory here so we are going to
do that now and assign that to this
mobile variable now mobile net was
originally trained on the image net
library just like vgg 16 so in a few
minutes we will be passing some images
to mobile net that i've saved on this
they are not images from the image net
library but they are images of some
general things and we're just going to
get an idea about how mobile net
performs on these random images but
first in order to be able to pass these
images to mobile net we're going to have
to do a little bit of processing first
so I've created this function called a
prepare image and what it does is it
takes a file name and it then inside the
function we have an image path which is
pointing to the location
disk where I have these saved image
files that we're going to use to get
predictions from mobile net so we have
this image path defined to where these
images are saved we then load the image
by using the image path and appending
the filename that we pass in so say if I
pass in image 1 dot PNG here then we're
going to take that file path append 1
PNG here pass that to load image and
pass this target size of 224 by 224 now
this load image function is from the
Charis api so what we are doing here is
we are just taking the image file
resizing it to be of size 224 by 224
because that is the size of images that
mobile net expects and then we just take
this image and transfer it to be in a
format of an array then we expand the
dimensions of this image because that's
going to put the image in the shape that
mobile net expects and then finally we
pass this new processed image to our
last function which is TF Kerris dot
applications stop mobile net that pre
process input so this is a similar
function to what we saw a few episodes
back when we were working with vgg 16 it
had its own pre process input now mobile
net has its own pre process input
function which is processing images in a
way that mobile net expects so it's not
the same way as bgg 16 actually it's
just scaling all the RGB pixel values to
be on a scale instead of from 0 to 255
to be on a scale from minus 1 to 1 so
that's what this function is doing so
overall this entire function is just
resizing the image and putting it into
an array format with expanded dimensions
and then mobile net processing it and
then returning this processed image ok
so that's kind of a mouthful but that's
what we got to do two images before we
pass them to mobile net all right so we
will just define that function and
now we are going to display our first
image called one dot PNG from our mobile
net samples directory that I told you I
just set up with a few random images and
we're going to plot that to our Jupiter
notebook here and what do you know it's
a lizard so that is our first image now
we are going to pass this image to our
prepare image function that we defined
right above that we just finished
talking about so we're going to pass
that to the function to pre-process the
image accordingly then we are going to
pass the pre processed image returned by
the function to our mobile net model
we're going to do that by calling
predict on the model just like we've
done in previous videos when we've
called predict on models to use them for
inference then after we get the
prediction for this particular image we
are then going to give this prediction
to this image net utils decode
predictions function so this is a
function from Charis that is just going
to return the top five predictions from
the 1000 possible image net classes and
it's going to tell us the top 5 that
mobile net is predicting for this image
so let's run that and then print out
those results and maybe you can have a
better idea of what I mean once you see
the printed output so we run this and we
have our output so these are the top 5
in order results from the image net
classes that mobile net is predicting
for this image so it's assigning a 58
percent probability to this image of
being an American chameleon
28 percent probability to green lizard
13 percent to a gamma and then we have
some small percentages here under 1% for
these other two types of lizards so it
turns out if you're not aware and I
don't know how you can not be aware of
this because everyone should know this
but this is an American chameleon and I
don't know I've always called these
things and green anoles but I looked it
up and they're also known as American
chameleons so mobile net got it right so
yeah it assigned that 58% probability
that was the highest most probable class
next was green lizard so I'd say that
that is still really good for that to be
your second place I don't know if green
lizard is supposed to be more general
but and then a gamma which is also a
similar-looking lizard if you didn't
know so between these top three classes
that it predicted this is almost 100%
between the three of these I would say
mobile and that did a pretty good job on
this prediction so let's move on to
number two all right so now we are going
to plot our second image and this is a
cup of well I originally thought that it
was espresso and then someone called it
a cup of cappuccino so let's say I'm not
sure I'm not a coffee connoisseur
although I do like both espresso and
cappuccinos this looks like it has some
cream in it so hey now we're going to go
through the same process of what we just
did for the lizard image where we are
passing that in passing this new image
to our prepare image function so that it
undergoes all of the pre-processing then
we are going to pass the pre processed
image to the predict function for our
mobile net model then finally we are
going to get the top five results from
the predictions for this model relative
regards to the image net classes so
let's see all right
so according to mobile net this is an
espresso not a cappuccino so I don't
know but it predicts 99 percent
probability of espresso as being the
most probable class for this particular
image and I'd say that that is pretty
reasonable so let me know in the
comments what do you think is this
espresso or cappuccino I don't know if
mobile or if image net had a cappuccino
class so if it didn't then I'd say that
this is pretty spot-on but you can see
that the other the other four
predictions are all less than 1% but
they are reasonable I mean the second
one is cup third eggnog fourth coffee
mug fifth wooden spoon gets a little bit
weird but there is
would there is a circular shape going on
here but these are all under 1% so
they're pretty negligible I would say
mobile net did a pretty great job at
giving a 99% probability to espresso for
this image all right we have one more
sample image so let's bring that in and
this is a strawberry or multiple
strawberries if you call if you consider
the background so same thing we are pre
processing the strawberry image then we
are getting a prediction for a mobile
net for this image and then we are
getting the top 5 results for the most
probable predictions among the 1000
images and we see that mobile net with
99.999 percent probability classifies
this image as a strawberry correctly so
very well and the rest are well well
under 1% but they are all fruits so
interesting another really good
prediction from mobile net so even with
the small reduction in accuracy that we
talked about at the beginning of this
episode you can probably tell from just
these three random samples that that
reduction is maybe not even noticeable
when you're just doing tests like the
ones that we just ran through so in
upcoming episodes we're actually going
to be fine-tuning this mobile net model
to work on a custom data set and this
custom data set is not one that was
included in the original image net
library it's going to be a brand new
data set we're gonna do more fine-tuning
than what we've done in the past so stay
tuned for that be sure to check out the
blog and other resources available for
this episode on deep lizard comm as well
as the depot's archive mind where you
can gain access to exclusive perks and
rewards thanks for contributing to
collective intelligence now let's move
on to the next episode
hey I'm Mandy from deep lizard in this
episode we'll be preparing and
processing a custom data set that will
use to fine-tune mobile net using tensor
flows Karis API
[Music]
previously we saw how well vgg 16 was
able to classify and generalize on
images of cats and dogs but we noted
that vgg 16 was actually already trained
on cats and dogs so it didn't take a lot
of fine-tuning at all to get it to
perform well on our cat and dog data set
now with mobile net will be going
through some fine-tuning steps as well
but this time we'll be working with a
dataset that is completely different
from the original image net library for
which mobile net was originally trained
on this new data set that we'll be
working with is the data set of images
of sign language digits there are ten
classes total for this data set ranging
from zero to nine where each class
contains images of the particular sign
for that digit this data set is
available on cattle as grayscale images
but it's also available on github as RGB
images and for our particular task we'll
be using the RGB images so check out the
corresponding belong' for this episode
on beep laser comm to get the link for
where you can download the data set
yourself so after downloading the data
set the next step is to organize the
data on disk and this will be a very
similar procedure to what we saw for the
cat and dog data set earlier in the
course so once we have the download this
is what it looks like it is a zip folder
called sign language digits data set
master and the first thing we want to do
is extract all the contents of this
directory and when we do that we can
navigate inside until we get to the data
set directory and inside here we have
all of the classes and each of these
directories has the corresponding images
for this particular class so what we
want to do is we want to grab 0 through
9 and we are going to control X or cut
these directories and we're going to
navigate back
to the root directory which is here
we're gonna place all of the directories
0 through 9 in this route and then we're
going to get rid of everything else by
deleting so now one last thing is I'm
just going to delete this master I don't
necessarily like that so we have sign
language digits data set and directly
within we have our nested directories
consisting of 0 through 9 each of which
has our training data inside then the
last step is to move the sign language
digits data set directory to where
you're going to be working so for me
that is relative to my Jupiter notebook
which lives inside of this deep learning
with Karis directory I have a data
directory and I have the sign language
digits data set located here now
everything else that will do to organize
and process the data will be done
programmatically in code so we are in
our Jupiter notebook make sure that you
do have the imports that we brought in
last time still in place because we'll
be making use of those now this is just
the class breakdown to let you know how
many images are in each class so across
the class is 0 through 9 the there are
anywhere from 204 to 208 samples in each
class and then here I have just an
explanation of how your data should be
structured up to this point
now the rest of the organization that we
will do programmatically with this
script here so this script is going to
organize the data into train valid and
test directories so recall right now we
just have all the data located in the
corresponding classes of 0 through 9 but
the data is not broken up yet into the
separate data sets of train tests and
validation so to do that we are first
changing directory into our sign
language digits data set directory and
then we are checking to make sure that
the directory structure that we're about
to set up is not already in place on
disk and if it's not then we make
trained valid and test directory right
within
sign-language digits dataset so next we
are then iterating over all of the
directories within our sign language
digits data set directory so we're
called those our directories labeled
zero through nine so that's what we're
doing in this for loop with this range
zero to ten that's going from directory
zero to nine and moving each of these
directories into our train directory and
after that we're then making two new
directories one inside of valid with the
directory for whatever place we're at in
the loop so if we are on run number zero
then we are making a directory called
zero with invalid and a directory called
zero within test and if we are on run
number one then we will be creating a
directory called one with invalid and
one within test so we do this whole
process of moving each class in to train
and then creating each class directory
empty within valid and tests so at this
point let's suppose that we are on the
first run in this for loop so in this
range here we are falling at number zero
so here on this line what we are doing
is we are sampling 30 samples from our
trained slash zero directory because up
here we created or we moved the class
directory 0 into train and now we are
going to sample 30 random samples from
the zero directory within train then so
we're calling these valid samples
because these are going to be these
samples that we move into our validation
set and we do that next so for each of
the 30 samples that we collected it from
the training set randomly in this line
we're now going to be moving them from
the training set to the validation 0 set
to the validation set in
class zero and then we do similarly the
same thing for the test samples we
randomly select five samples from the
train slash zero directory and then we
move those five samples from that train
slash zero directory into the test zero
directory so we just ran through that
loop using the class zero as an example
but that's going to happen for each
class zero through nine and just in case
you have any issue with visualizing what
that script does if we go into sign
language digits data set now let's check
out how we have organized the data so
recall we previously had classes 0
through 9 all listed directly here
within the this root folder now we have
train valid and test directories and
within train we moved the original 0
through 9 directories all into train and
then once that was done then we sampled
30 images from each of these classes and
moved them into the valid directory
classes and then similarly we did the
same thing for the test directory and
then once we look in here we can see
that the test directory has 5 samples
for 0 we see that it has 5 samples for 1
if we go check out the valid directories
look at 0 it should have 30 zeros so we
see that here 30 so every valid
directory has 30 samples and the
training directory classes have not
necessarily uniform samples because
remember we saw that the number of
samples in each class ranged anywhere
from 204 to 209 I think so
the the number of images within each
class directory for the training sample
will differ slightly by maybe one or two
images but the number of images in the
classes for the validation and test
directories will be uniform since
we did that programmatically with our
script here so checking this data set
out on disk we can see that this is
exactly the same format for which we
structured our cat-and-dog
image data set earlier in the course now
we're just dealing with tin classes
instead of two and when we downloaded
our data it was in a slightly different
organizational structure than the
cat-and-dog data that we previously
downloaded all right so we have obtained
the data we've organized the data now
the last step is to pre-process the data
so we do that first by starting out by
defining where our trained valid and
test directories live on disk so we
supply those paths here and now we are
setting up our directory iterators which
we should be familiar with at this point
given this is the same format that we
processed our cat and dog images
whenever we built our CNN from scratch
and we use the fine-tuned vgg 16 model
so let's focus on this first variable
train batches first we are calling image
data generator dot flow from directory
which we can't quite see here but we'll
scroll in just a minute
to image data generator we are passing
this pre-processing function which in
this case is the mobile net
pre-processing function recall we saw
that already in the last episode and
there we discussed how this pre
processes images in such a way that it
scales the image data to be rather than
on a scale from 0 to 255 to instead be
on a scale from minus 1 to 1 so then on
image data generator we call slow from
directory which is flowing off the
screen here and we set the directory
equal to train path which we have
defined just above saying where our
training data resides on disk we are
setting the target size 2 to 24 by 224
which recall just resizes any training
data to be a height or to have a height
of 224 in a width of 224 since that is
the image size that mobile net expects
and we are setting our batch size equal
to ten so we've got the same deal for
valid batches and for test batches as
well everything exactly the same except
for the paths differing to show where
the validation and test sets live on
disk and we are familiar now that we
specify shuffle equals false only for
our test set so that we can later
appropriately plot our prediction
results to a confusion matrix so we run
this cell and we have output that we
have 1700 and 12 images belonging to 10
classes so that corresponds to our
training set 300 images to 10 classes
for our validation set and 50 images
belonging to 10 classes for our test set
so I have this cell with several
assertions here which just assert that
this output that we find or that we have
right here is what we expect so if you
are not getting this then it's perhaps
because you are pointing to the wrong
location on disk so a lot of times if
you're pointing to the wrong location
then you'll probably get found zero
images belonging to ten classes so you
just need to check your path to where
your data set resides if you get that
all right so now our data set has been
processed we're now ready to move on to
building and fine-tuning our mobile net
model for this data set be sure to check
out the blog and other resources
available for this episode on B+ or comm
as well as the depot's or hive mind
where you can gain access to exclusive
perks and rewards thanks for
contributing to collective intelligence
now let's move on to the next episode
hey I'm Mandy from deep lizard in this
episode we'll go through the process of
fine-tuning mobile net for a custom data
set
[Music]
all right so we are jumping right back
into our Jupiter notebook from last time
so make sure your code is in place from
then since we will be building it
directly on that now so the first thing
we're going to do is we are going to
import mobile net just as we did in the
first mobile net episode by calling TF
Harris the applications not mobile in
that mobile net remember if this is your
first time running this line then you
will need an internet connection to
download it from the internet now let's
just take a look at the model that we
downloaded so by calling model dot
summary we have this output here that is
showing us all of these lovely layers
included in mobile net so this is just
to get a general idea of the model
because we will be fine-tuning it so the
fine tuning process now is going to
start out with us getting all of the
layers up to the sixth to last layer so
if we scroll up and look at our output
one two three four five six so we are
going to get all of these layers up to
this layer and everything else is not
going to be included so all these layers
are what we are going to keep and
transfer into a new model our new
fine-tuned model and we are not going to
include these last five layers and this
is just a choice that I came to after
doing a little experimenting and testing
the number of layers that you choose to
include versus not include whenever
you're fine-tuning a model is going to
come through experimentation and
personal choice so for for us we are
getting everything from this layer and
above and we are going to keep that in
our new fine-tuned model so let's scroll
down so we're doing that by calling
mobile layers passing in that sixth to
last layer and output then we are going
to create a variable called output and
we're going to set this equal to a dense
layer with
ten units so this is going to be our
output layer that's why it's called
output and ten units due to the nature
of our classes ranging zero through nine
and this as per usual is going to be
followed by a softmax activation
function to give us a probability
distribution among those ten outputs now
this looks a little strange so we're
calling this and then we're like putting
this X variable next to it so what's
this about
well the mobile net model is actually a
functional model so this is from the
functional API from Charis not the
sequential API so we kind of touched on
this a little bit earlier whenever we
fine-tuned at vgg 16 we saw that vgg 16
was also indeed a functional model but
when we fine-tuned it we iterated over
each of the layers and added them to a
sequential model at that point because
we weren't ready to introduce the
functional model yet so here we are
going to continue working with a
functional model type so that's why we
are basically taking all of the layers
here up to the sixth to last and
whenever we create this output layer and
then call this the previous layers
stored in X here that is the way that
the functional model works we're
basically saying to this output layer
pass all of the previous layers that we
have stored in X up to the sixth to last
layer and mobile net and then we can
create the model using these two pieces
X and output by saying by calling model
which is indeed a functional model when
specified this way and specifying inputs
equals mobile dot input so this is
taking the input from the original
mobile net model and outputs equals
output so at this point output is all of
the mobile net model up until the six to
last layer plus this dense
output layer all right so let's run
these two cell
to create our new model all right so our
new models now been created so the next
thing we're going to do is we're going
to go through and freeze some layers so
through some experimentation of my own I
have found that if we freeze all except
for the last 23 layers this appears to
yield some decent results so 23 is not a
magic number here play with this
yourself and let me know if you get
better results but basically what we're
doing here is we're going through all
the layers in the model and by default
they are all trainable so we're saying
that we want only the last 23 layers to
be trainable all the layers except for
the last 23 make those not trainable and
just so that you understand relatively
speaking there are 88 total layers in
the original mobile net model and so
we're saying that we don't want to Train
or that we only want to train the last
23 layers in our new model that we built
just above recall this is much more than
we earlier trained with our fine-tuned
vgg 16 model where we only trained the
output layer so let's go ahead and run
that now and now let's look at a summary
of our new fine-tuned model so here if
we just glance it looks basically the
same is what we solve from our original
summary but we will see here that now
our now our model ends with this global
average pooling 2d layer which recall
before was the sixth to last layer where
I said that we would include that layer
and everything above it so all the
layers below the global average pooling
layer that we previously saw in the
original mobile net summary are now gone
and instead of an output layer with
1,000 classes we now have an output
layer with ten classes from the or
corresponding to the ten potential
output classes that we have for our new
sign language stitches dataset if we
compare the total parameters and how
they're split amongst trainable and non
trainable parameters
in this model with the original mobile
mobile that model then we will see a
difference there as well
alright so now this model has been built
we are ready to train the model so the
code here is nothing new we are
compiling the model in the same exact
fashion using the atom optimizer zero
point zero zero zero point zero zero
zero one a learning rate categorical
categorical cross entropy loss and
accuracy as our metric so this we have
probably seen two million times up to
this point in this course so that's
exactly the same additionally we have
exactly the same fit function that we
are running to train the model so we're
passing in our train batches as our data
set we are passing in validation batches
as our validation data and we are
running this for 10 a pouts actually
we're going to go ahead and run this for
30 I had 10 here just to save time
earlier from testing but we're going to
run this for 30 bucks and we are going
to set verbose equal to 2 to get the
most verbose output now let's see what
happens all right so our model just
finished training over 30 epochs so
let's check out the results and if you
see this output and you're wondering why
the first output to 90 seconds and then
we got or the first epoch to at 90
seconds and then we got it down to 5
seconds just a few later it's because I
realized that I was running on battery
and not on my laptop being plugged in so
once we plug the laptop in it beefed up
and started running much quicker so
let's scroll down and look basically
just like how we ended here so we are at
100% accuracy on our training set and
92% accuracy on our validation set so
that is pretty frickin great considering
the fact that this is a completely new
data set not having images that were
included in the original image net model
so these are pretty good results a
little bit overfitting here since our
validation accuracy is lower than our
training accuracy so if we want
to fix that then we could take some
necessary steps to combat that
overfitting issue but if we look only at
the earlier epochs to see what kind of
story is being told here on our first
epoch our training accuracy actually
starts out at 74 percent among ten
classes so that is not bad for a
starting point and we quickly get to 100
percent on our training accuracy just
within four epochs so that's great but
you can see that at that point we're
only at 81 percent accuracy for our
validation set so we have a decent
amount of overfitting going on earlier
on here and then as we progress through
the training process the overfitting is
becoming less and less of a problem and
you can see that we actually at this
point if we just look at the last eight
epoch set of run here we've not even
stalled out yet on our validation loss
it's not stalled out in terms of
decreasing and our valve our validation
accuracy has not sought out in terms of
increasing so perhaps just running more
epochs on this data will eradicate the
overfitting problem otherwise you can do
some tuning yourself changing some hyper
parameters around do a different
structure of fine tuning on the model so
freeze more or less than the last 23
layers for during the fine-tuning
process or just experiment yourself and
if you come up with something that
yields better results than this then put
it in the comments and let us know so we
have one last thing we want to do with
our fine-tuned mobile net model and that
is use it on our test set so we are
familiar you know the drill with this
procedure at this point we have done it
several times so we are now going to get
predictions from the model on our test
set and then we are going to plot those
predictions to a confusion matrix so we
are first going to get our true labels
by calling test Baptist classes or then
going to gain predictions from the model
by calling model dot
and passing in our test set stored in
test batches here setting verbose equal
to zero because we do not want to see
any output from the predictions and now
we are creating our confusion matrix
using scikit-learn it's confusion matrix
that we imported earlier we are setting
our true labels equal to the test labels
that we define just here above we are
setting our predicted labels to the Arg
max of our predictions across axis one
and now we are going to check out our
class indices of the test batches just
to make sure they are what we think they
are and they are of course classes
labeled as 0 through 9 so we define our
labels for our confusion matrix here
accordingly and then we call our plot
confusion matrix that we brought in
earlier in the notebook and that we have
used 17,000 times up to this point in
this course and we are passing in our
confusion matrix for what to plot we are
passing in our labels that we want to
correspond to our confusion matrix and
giving our confusion matrix the very
general title of confusion matrix
because hey that's what it is
so let's plot this oh no so plot
confusion matrix is not defined well it
definitely is just somewhere in this
notebook I must have skipped over it
here we go nope
here we are alright so here's where plot
confusion matrix is defined let's bring
that in now it is defined and run back
here so looking from the top left to the
bottom right diagonal we see that the
model appears to have done pretty well
so we have ten classes total with five
samples per class and we see that we
have mostly we have all fours and fives
across this diagonal meaning that most
of the time the model predicted
correctly so for example for a nine five
times out of five the model predicted an
image was a nine when it actually was
for an eight however only four out of
five times did the model correctly
predict looks
one of the times the model let's see
predicted a one when it should have been
an eight but in total we've got one two
three four five incorrect predictions
out of 50 total so that gives us a 90
percent accuracy rate on our test set
which is not surprising for us given the
accuracy that we saw right above on our
validation set
so hopefully this series on a mobile net
insight to how we can fine tune models
for custom data set and use transfer
learning to use the information that a
model gained from its original training
set on a completely new task in the
future be sure to check out the blog and
other resources available for this
episode on beep laser comm as well as
the depot's archive mind where you can
gain access to exclusive perks and
rewards thanks for contributing to
collective intelligence now let's move
on to the next episode
hey I'm Mandy from deep lizard and in
this episode we're going to learn how we
can use data augmentation on images
using tensor flows caris API data
augmentation occurs when we create a new
data by making modifications to some
existing data we're going to explain the
idea a little bit further Before we jump
into the code but if you want a more
thorough explanation then be sure to
check out the corresponding episode in
the deep learning fundamentals course on
deep lizard calm for the example that
we'll demonstrate in just a moment the
data we'll be working with is image data
and so for image data specifically data
augmentation would include things like
slipping the image either horizontally
or vertically
it could include rotating the image it
could include changing the color of the
image and so on one of the major reasons
we'd want to use data augmentation is to
simply just get access to more data so a
lot of times not having access to enough
data
is an issue that we can run into and we
can run into problems like overfitting
if our training data set is too small so
that is a major reason to use data
augmentation is to just grow our
training set
adding augmented data to our training
set can in turn reduce overfitting as
well all right so now let's jump into
the code to see how we can augment image
data using Kerris alright so the first
thing that we need to do of course is
import all of the packages that we will
be making use of for this data
augmentation next we have this plot
images function which we've introduced
earlier in the course this is directly
from tensor flows website and it just
allows us to apply images to our Jupiter
notebook so check out the corresponding
vlog for this episode on V Blizzard comm
to get the link so that you can go copy
this function yourself all right so next
we have this variable called Gen which
is an image data generator and recall
we've actually worked with image data
generators earlier in the course
whenever we create our train tests and
valid batches that we were using for
training cnn's with this so we are using
image data generator in a different way
here we are creating this generator that
we are specifying all of these
parameters like rotation range width
shift range height shift range share
range zoom range channel shift range in
horizontal flip so these are all options
that allow us to augment our image data
so you need to check the documentation
on Kinser flows website to get an idea
of the units for these parameters
because they're not all the same so for
example rotation range here I believe is
measured in radians whereas like this
width
shift range is measured as a percentage
of the width of the image so these are
all ways that we can augment image data
so this is going to be rotating the
image by 10 radians this is going to be
shifting the width of the image by 10%
the height by 10%
zooming in shifting the
color channels flipping the image so all
sorts of things so just all different
ways that we can augment image data so
there are other options to just be sure
to check out the image data generator
documentation if you want to see those
options but for now these are the ones
that we'll be working with so we store
that in our gen variable next we are
going to choose a random image from a
dog directory that we had set up earlier
in the course under the dogs vs. cats
data set we're going to go into train
into dog and then we are going to choose
a random image from this directory and
then we're going to set this image path
accordingly so we're just going to set
this to point to whatever that chosen
image was on disk then we have this
assertion here just to make sure that
that is indeed a valid file before we
proceed with the remaining code now
we're just going to plot this image to
the screen and I'm not sure what this is
going to be since it is a random image
from disk so that is a cute looking I
don't know beagle beagle basset hound
mix I don't know what do you guys think
so this is the random dog that was
selected from from our dog train
directory now we are creating this new
variable called Agadir and to our image
data generator that we created earlier
called gin we are calling this flow
function and passing our image in to
flow and this is going to generate a
batch of augmented images from this
single image so next we are defining
this aughh images variable which is
going to give us ten samples of the
augmented images created by OGG itter
here lastly we are going to plot these
images using the plot images that we
defined just above all right so let's
zoom in a bit all right we can see now
that first let's take a look at our
original dog all right so that is the
original image now we
can look and see that given those things
like rotation and width shift and
everything that we defined earlier
whenever we defined whenever we defined
our image data generator that has now
been done to all of these images in one
a random way or another so we can see
kind of what's happening here so for
example this particular image looks like
it has been shifted up some because we
can see that the head of the dog is
being cut off a little bit and this
image or let's see which way was the dog
originally facing so it's head is facing
to the right so yes so this image here
has been flipped the dog is now facing
to the left and this image appears to be
shifted down some and so some of these
like this one looks like it's been
rotated so we can get an idea just by
looking at the images the types of data
augmentations that have been done to
them and we can see how this could be
very helpful for growing our dataset in
general because for example say that we
have a bunch of images of dogs but for
whatever reason they're all facing to
the left and we want to deploy our model
to to be some general model that will
classify different dogs but the types of
images that will be accepted by this
model later might have dogs facing to
the right as well well maybe our model
totally implodes on itself whenever it
receives a dog facing to the right so
through data augmentation given the fact
that it is very normal for dogs to face
left or right we could augment all of
our dog images to have the data or to
have the dogs also face in the right
direction as well as the left direction
to have a more to have a more dynamic
data set now there is a note in the
corresponding blog for this episode on D
poster calm giving just the brief
instruction for how to save these images
to disk if you want to save the images
after you augment them and then add them
back to your training set so check that
out if you're interested in doing that
to actually grow your training set
rather than just plot
images here in your Jupiter notebook by
the way we are currently in Vietnam
filming this episode if you didn't know
we also have a vlog channel where we
document our travels and share a little
bit more about ourselves so check that
out at people's our vlog on YouTube also
be sure to check out the corresponding
blog for this episode along with other
resources available on v+ or calm and
check out the deals or type mind where
you can gain exclusive access to perks
and rewards thanks for contributing to
collective intelligence I'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]